all right and we are
live the last word with lord cognito
ibontis and ty guy travis
on that friday evening campfire
back again good to see your faces
i got all the slander while i was sick
but it's good to be back
first let's start with e you know saying
we do have a very special guest but
let's start with e man
how are you doing brother uh been good i
beat returnal
so wow i've rolled credits on that thing
um
that is a fantastic journey it's kind of
one of those like how do i tell somebody
about it's like third person shooter
bullet hell from the old arcades and
also roguelike with an insanely cryptic
story
yet when you get to the end and you're
all the credits i'm like damn it was
it was really cool like i'd taken a
break from it for like a good few weeks
and trying to do other things and
finally i was like i picked it up again
started going and just like started
making progress beat the third boss
which was kind of
a wall and then the fifth one as well
yeah it just kind of started to come
together found a weapon i really liked
and
yeah finally got to the end and was
sitting there i finished it off stream
sadly because i was just like hey let me
kick on and see if i can get a run going
and sure enough i'm sitting there in the
last like 30 minutes like i think i'm
near the boss so i just like yeah
i literally streamed it to my discord
for a couple of people that i know my
regulars in here oh okay
i got recorded it but yeah it was that
was really cool um
so yeah that was my big one for the week
everything else has been pretty chill
the usual grind
travis what have you been up to uh i
know one of them because it got
published today
what have you been doing man i'm doing
reviews and previews all week for ign
it's been an incredibly busy week what
with
ign's first which is focusing on the
steam deck the guy
great coverage you guys got that scoop
ryan mccaffery he's the
goal the legend uh yeah so that was huge
uh we unveiled the new uh strategy game
uh i wasn't really part of that coverage
and then um
the new switch uh they covered that as
well and then i did
uh the review of skyward sword hd
uh i did a preview for origami 2 which
was also an ign exclusive and then
a preview for an upcoming mmo called
ashes of creation so
really busy week for me man but uh it's
mostly in the in the in the rear view
and now i'm
focusing on the new ace attorney game
that's coming out uh i'm starting to
play that so that's the the next thing
i'll be working on
you're in a grind sir you're in the
ground yeah i know it's been a really
good week i think we got somebody
special here yeah so let's
yeah we got a guest he's sitting there
patiently waiting so let's add him to
the campfire the best way we know how
this one's yours sir welcome
thanks for the last word which i'm not
done with you yeah nice intro
[Laughter]
welcome to the last word episode number
158
and it's glorious friday we're back in
front of the campfire for some more
lunar shooter discussion
i'm extremely excited about our special
guests so we're going to get right into
it
i want to introduce a lord whose
analytical and helpful approach to end
game content
represents the epitome of low man
challenges and informative guide strats
all done with a hilarious sense of humor
introducing the creating host of the
above youtube and twitch channel and
proud member of
clan obtained the lord of
boss bakes and grand master gauntlets
who still puts those gods on the line
for the people to decide
live from seattle and making his debut
at the campfire of the last
word mommy lord above how we doing sir
oh my goodness i don't think i'm worthy
of that intro i'm like sweating from
that
um thank you for having me on
oh i did your research holy mo i mean
you gassed it up like way
it could be way cooler than it is but
this is why you can't interrupt the
intro
it interrupted me
you've been killing brother glad to have
you
i appreciate it i've been good um so
yeah i i actually just went full time as
a content creator last month and so
the last 30 days has been
wild to say the least like especially
with uh
gm season rolling around and master vlog
dropping
and uh yeah it's been crazy busy but
loving every second
nice nice so we got a lot of questions
for him you know what i mean so
you want to set it all first yeah i kind
of like your gaming history
for what you kind of started off with
and who you got to play it with so
just a little recap of who you actually
started your gaming journey with because
not everybody gets to do that and i just
wanted to make sure we kind of get to
share this one with everybody
yep um yeah so i actually started my the
first like the first
fond memory i have of gaming was
actually um you know i mean i'm way past
my prime now so
we're going all the way back to the n64
days we're older than you you're fine
it was actually mario 64 with my mom we
were playing
in our playroom like i remember it we
would just
she she introduced me to video games she
like
fell in love with it and then we played
through um i don't know if you guys have
played that game before but um
later yeah 120 stars we got 119
we could never get 120. this was before
youtube and guides and everything else
which maybe is what inspired me
to do guides on youtube i don't know
maybe that's you know
it's subtle messaging but uh yeah i just
have
such fond memories of doing that with my
mom uh and then i just kind of gamed all
my life um
yeah but it all started with her no
doubt no doubt awesome
yeah i have any other questions to start
with the history any other questions
before we
i jump in yeah uh i mean is it too early
to get into the how
he got into destiny thing go wherever
you want to go with it really
yeah uh so yeah you mentioned obviously
uh super mario which
i also love that game as a kid and had
the same issue of not having the
internet
like the guide for me was you ask your
friends like
did you did you find all the stars in
this world and that sort of stuff
uh which i loved um but yeah but
obviously destiny is a pretty
different game uh from from you know a
collect-a-thon
platformer so how did you sort of get
into the shooter world or get introduced
to bungie specifically and find your
yourself as a destiny guy i've always
been like
extremely competitive so in high school
i played
uh baseball and then as that part of my
life kind of faded out
um i picked up video games to fulfill
like my
competitive side um and so
in the late parts of high school early
college i got i became a
semi-professional call of duty player
um like we would scrim against like
optic and stuff and
oh and all sorts of that so yeah i mean
i took it like very seriously while i
was going to school
um and then that kind of just faded out
uh kind of lost interest in cod and then
a bunch of my friends like as
you know school picked up and you know
your your capstone classes towards the
end of college really start kicking and
you have less time
i picked up destiny casually um and this
was like right as it was coming out so
played the beta
loved it and then it came out and all of
our friends did vault of glass
um when we eventually got leveled did it
completely blind no spoilers we did the
same thing with crota
um loved it and then i actually took a
hiatus
uh during college because super focused
i got a um
i got an internship i studied business
and marketing in college
and i got an internship with a uh
what's it called a pr firm so i was
with them for a couple years wasn't
really playing video games all that much
so i played like
fifa on the side casually and things
like that and then
right before destiny 2 came out like i i
loved it so much it was just when the
crota era
rolled around there wasn't much to do
i'm sure you guys remember those days it
was kind of like
okay we did it now we're kind of just
waiting here
all the content content droughts yeah so
i stopped playing
um but then i saw destiny 2 was coming
in i was like oh my god
i'm so excited about this because i had
more time now is more stable with my job
um and i got back into destiny 1
like a few weeks before d2 dropped
the hell out of everything yeah like i
did everything in like a month
um and then i was so hyped for d2 and
have been playing
pretty much since launch no doubt no
doubt
this is cool history oh i want to stay
back on destiny
so in the beginning because we got to
have some some subclass violence
um yeah i was like after this podcast on
this side just yes yes
yes yes you know i'm i'm sensing
a man of culture i'm sensing a man that
wears those
royal clothes but i'm feeling warlock
vibes but yet
i still feel i see that that thing
behind you and i'm concerned
he's a hunter he has it on his wall quit
trying to make no
he's trying to reach cognitive like he
was like you're a fluffy boy aren't you
a very very astuteous gentleman he's
very he's very cultured and i
i just it seems to go against this thing
in the back
well yeah cox is just reaching right now
this is this is fun
everything shifted so much so in d1
literally all i played was night stalker
that's like that that was
i mean that was it uh beginning of d2 i
was night stalker maine
i i played nothing else didn't have any
other characters
so and that's actually like when i
bought these uh it was like years and
years ago and then
icarus dash came out and well came out
and i was like dude
a couple locks are pretty sweet i'm
gonna start playing them
um and so i did a couple day one races
on warlocks and then uh i did dsc
on a warlock uh which we finished 56th
and that one and then
recently on vlog i played a hunter and
we got
uh 31st so i can't i play both the
titans are tough
right like talk to him get him
yes yeah no you don't worry don't worry
speak freely you are not
is between d1 and d2 those bubbles and
those signal shields do seem to
have some importance every so often i'm
just going to leave that out there
so it just didn't appeal to the man
continue above
oh yeah so uh yeah i'm kind of like a
split between hunter warlock
uh those are my two i play titan
sometimes they have dude
the curious titan exotic is a lot of fun
i'm not going to lie just bashing your
head again
killing it instantly is pretty cool so
that's how we do it
yeah before before i pass it back to you
i just got to ask the favorite if you
you can only have one of those
subclasses you know within either the
warlock or the hunter tree
what's the favorite oh man
at its peak uh i'm not sure you guys
remember oppressive darkness when that
was around
uh yeah a little bit nova bomb
controvers
so much fun doing that uh that would
probably be my favorite
will did the darkness and avoid you this
is a good guy i like this guess
questioning's done on my side so please
pass the flight and customization
and incognito's over here like check
connections welcome back every time at
the campfire sir
why couldn't he be on last episode when
we had three titans seriously
yeah travis sarah we're just talking all
titans would love to have the minority
then
i will say this about titans i have some
teammates actually one of which
uh one of my day one teammates just got
world second solo atheon last night his
name's t
uh he's uh i mean i have huge respect
for really good titan players because
they make a
very big difference i just personally
i'm not a fan but yeah they're they're
incredibly uh underrated because i feel
like they're kind of the backbone of
your team
they do all of the the dirty work but
don't get all the credit you know what
i'm saying so
we're back there doing the squats and
the deadlifts and you guys are up there
like flexing all the
all the little details yeah i said that
though but yeah i mean i guess they're
they're all right they're all right
people like skipped leg day i see what
you're doing yeah
warlocks definitely skip leg day they're
wearing dresses to cover up those
chicken legs are you kidding me we're
reflecting the the brain fibers you know
we do all the cognitive work
well you know smarter not harder
everybody's got a different role i guess
that's the thing we'll just carry you on
our back it's fine
uh i did want to actually kind of catch
one story though you said like in
college
you know shout out by the way to uh the
world of being married but yeah you
actually moved in
how did you meet your wife because like
i want a little more of the story so
tell us like how that actually happened
because it seems
proximity worked she's in chat right now
actually she's a
love and chat um but yeah so hello i
actually went to a community college
near me for two years and then when i
was a
going into my junior year i transferred
to
uh western which is up north from me uh
in the seattle area
and um yeah i i literally
saw these apartments out of the corner
matters i was like dad those look pretty
nice we should go check those out
moved in and uh turns out i moved into
the
next door to the my future wife so kind
of a crazy
that's literally the girl next door so
like yeah we ended up uh
we hit it off and the rest is history i
mean is there like a movie scene where
you're like you're both watching walking
groceries upstairs you turn and look and
be like
she's cute you go inside later on
she drops that tomato that just rolls
down the stairs
i've got your tomato would you like your
tomato
um honestly there is a story we told it
at our wedding so
as a college student she had no idea how
much
uh salmon was like normal to buy at a
store
so she bought three pounds of salmon for
herself
um and so naturally she was like yeah
there's no way i'm gonna be able to eat
all this so
she knocked on her door and was like hey
i don't have a grill do you guys want to
grill the salmon for me and like
being broke college students next door
to a really attractive girl we were like
yeah i'm going to figure this out yeah
yeah
we're doubt like is there a catch that
we should be aware like what's happening
um so yeah we uh where's the boyfriend
when is he coming over to eat the salad
it is it is it's weird it's a wild story
but uh
yeah she so we grilled and she brought a
nice bottle of wine and we just hit it
off and
the rest is history we've been married
uh five years
in about a month congratulations that's
right
five did she buy the whole fish
did she buy like the whole fish or was
it just like all at once
like she bought like the pack leader the
i mean
like like the costco yeah like you know
the jumbo i don't know we were just like
what happened like where did we go wrong
but i'm glad she did i'm glad she had no
idea what she was doing shopping
there's nothing wrong with that that's
that's actually really awesome though i
saw that and i was like the next door
i'm like all right i want to know the
story it's like is this a movie
and shout out to your golden retriever
maddie by the way because my dogs are
they want to be on show too if you can't
hear them so that's awesome
yeah we uh that's our that's our kid
before the kid that's how we're
we're training so to speak it's a nice
baby step
they have a lot of similarities here
yes see see what i did there i see yes i
see the vision
trap what you got there anything else
well our uh our go-to question on this
show
or sorry their go-to question on this
show uh since i'm just crashing it
is uh uh your favorite raid
destiny or if you had their own man if
you prefer to do a top three ranking
sunsetted or not like like all time top
three franchise is usually what we do
yeah okay i have i haven't
since you've been around long enough to
see them all like
he's like i've never done a race this
might get me in trouble but
i've never done king's fall ever whoa
literally said you did everything that's
a big giant lie now
no you said you did d1 and you had a
month yeah i did everything caught up
on youtube it was a big show
so here's the thing i mean it's kind of
a big deal for me to get into helps
honestly was i was a solo player when i
came back i had like nobody to play with
and
you know not having the in-game lfg so i
wanted to create a community where it
was like
a very friendly environment people could
come in and learn and not
you know feel bad that they don't know
all the raid mechanics you know they
don't
you know know what to do as a t storm
would like to put on lfg
um but uh yeah i don't know um
never did that one but top three raids
all time for me
um in terms of most memorable i think
just surrounding everything
last wish would have to be number one
just because
i remember it was before i got into like
really
i guess the quote-unquote competitive
side of destiny like actually raiding
for
worlds first and that sort of thing um
that was still a little bit before i
started diving into it
but i remember just the hype leading up
and the the power grind and getting to
the dreaming city
yeah i think it was everything
surrounding it that made it so special
like
end game destination so much like
it's such a grind leading up to it and
then you get in there and it's just
a banger from start to finish they just
knocked it out of the park
and then everything that cascaded off of
the raid too i mean you have the story
you know uh my my good friend evan made
a video online
i mean the story of that is just the
storytelling
behind that is just incredible and then
you know it led to the corrupted coming
out and
shattered thrown three weeks later which
is something we had never experienced
before
so talk to him for me it has to be that
has to be number one
i like it i gotta respect it man i tell
people a lot like i don't get bad when
people say
last wish especially what you said like
the lead up getting the talisman done
just to get to the dreamy city then you
get to the dreaming city
and it's just beautiful looking like
some tolkien
you don't say a lot of rick like it
looked amazing and then like you said
the lord
shattered thrown fire all right what's
what's the voice number two and three we
gotta know
man i'm still waiting for the person to
come on here and just say leviathan
number one and just drop mike
i respect what he did really cool idea
the environment was incredible but the
rep
the replayability just wasn't there for
me um
man that's tough uh probably wrath
number two
oh very fun read now you're talking cox
language
yeah very fundraised very fun rave
underrated encounters yes yeah very they
still haven't really replicated anything
like that travis right
i don't know yeah i mean it's a moving
encounter that's a very large space and
they really don't do that that much i
mean
what about cerro cheese the only like
there's a rare one where you're actually
traversing yeah but just the scale of
the siege machine too is yeah it's legit
yeah
the little cars got to a train heist and
yes
that is true one more one
this might this one might be
controversial part of it is i mean it's
definitely nostalgia
um every one of these with something you
know man because everybody's like
well what the hell let's go one two
three and leave it there and let
everybody have already done with you
i'm like you know all right listen no he
he justified the last was totally fine i
have nothing wrong with that
i know why oh sorry go ahead go ahead go
go go go
go go go i was just gonna say i think
for me
because vog was the first i mean for
everybody was the first raid pretty much
that most destiny uh long-term players
did
i think they did a magnificent job
bringing it into d2 like the base
version
the day one race and how they structured
that was actually
such a good time i think it was super
well received by the community
the master version not so fond of
um but that day one race and tempo's
edge the challenge version
uh to actually compete for day one was
really
really fun i thought they they kept the
identity of the raid
and adding a few mechanics in that
stressed communication so much more than
the base rate did so yeah everybody
feels like they're doing something and
it
kept the identity really well so yeah i
think uh probably vog number three
agreed especially with the the oracle
call out stuff
it was it was they added a little bit
more and i want to shout you out though
because um
you put me on to something about fog
that i didn't even realize and i got to
shout you out was um
that that void mod what is this super
structure
your first structured defense oh i did
not know about that i
you know i came across your video i
didn't know your time and your video
came up and i was just like
yo this is super powerful that stacks
were like breaching
and clearing all this stuff i'm like yo
everything is getting changed to void
immediately yeah but now salute to you
on that um yeah vlog obviously you know
it's nostalgic but i will say this i'm a
surprise e right now
it is criminal that you have not played
king's fall
and what i'm hoping what i'm hoping is
we do get
you know in the legacy content that re
reimagined because it was gonna it's
gonna be cool for you to experience in
the first time
because don't get me wrong it's it's a
high point of contention here
but at the end of the day i would i
cannot disrespect kings four it is
an amazing that is a rage i've heard
i've heard it's just he's like i know
i've been told
six thousand times i have and it's tough
because
i wanna go back and play it but i like i
don't have a console right now and it's
like
i really want to you also don't want to
go play in like the slimy
vaseline molasses 30 frames per second
you can't do that
you can't go back plus they're
unvaulting stuff and it's like how far
away really is king's fall like it could
be
you know i mean it could be the next
rate they do it's like it's july or
august of next year
but um but then it the other
thing is like you know i'm very
competitive on day one races so i'm
gonna
and i i have no idea i've not watched a
second on it and that's
i to go in eventually and and do it
completely
but if it comes out for the day one race
i'm gonna have to just research it ahead
of time i'm
like i have to otherwise we're not gonna
be able to repeat you don't know about
the date
or you don't know about the final boss i
know i've seen
like little bits i don't know like the
actual mechanics i've seen
oh please go blind it's i know you do
day ones but honestly like i'm probably
going to borrow try and do blind
i think i got a better console and going
blind on a day where it's like you know
it doesn't really mean anything because
i i want to compete in that day one race
but
yeah if you definitely want to go in
blind as well if you haven't seen it and
you haven't
actually been that spoiled i'm surprised
if you can find a way at some point yeah
it's like i would have looked it up
right now intentional people have been
like dude just watch
like you need to just well i'm like no i
really don't i don't want to i want to
have that opportunity someday so yeah if
we're going to bring it on xbox i bet
you [ __ ] and i would do it with you
oh yeah i did that definitely i'll
figure out a way if you all want to do
that i'm
i'm more than down i would love to we're
still what a season away from our cross
play but it's not we got to get ian
that's his
i can't do it what i eat like that's his
raid i would have to do it
wow yeah like come on yeah like at the
end of the day
we fought blood tears over there and
even though i love it it's it's a matter
of you know
comparing picassos at the end of the day
it's like
it is a great raid yeah i would love to
experience that all of us we should we
do it together
i would love to that'd be i'd be awesome
no doubt no doubt
e what you got me uh well
it's been an interesting week and
since he actually mentioned it before we
got to see
master vog challenge number two and
since we have a man who is fresh off the
take on it
i actually wanted to get his thoughts on
just master vog for the two weeks we've
had so far and then just the master
the way master has been implemented for
vog in general since
difficulty hasn't been a thing in raids
for a while especially done in this way
and i wanted to get his take on it so it
seemed like a perfect way to
lead into current activities sir
awesome um
[Music]
this is going to be another preface
moment um so i want to
i like giving feedback respect you're
going to have footnotes and answer
tricks and everything in the script
i love the idea of multiple levels of
raids like
d1 hard mode i i did a couple of those
that was real like probably the
highlight of destiny for me
um i love that they're doing that in d2
i hate that most of it's artificial
um like even though i spend a lot of
time in grand masters
and i know that they have you know
obviously witch queen coming up so a lot
of their dev teams assigned to
uh you know that side of the the content
i think even adapting
small changes into mechanics instead of
it all
being artifact power leveling that no
one wants to do
and the fact that you can over level for
it i feel like they would have just been
better off doing a contest modifier
you need to be a minimum base power
which just make it the max power
and you know the whatever like the plus
15 on the artifact
um make people go in under contest it
seems like a really fair balance
and then you add in those negative
modifiers that aren't that bad
and i think people would have it'd be
more approachable but still harder than
the regular version
um and i've heard friends of mine say
like you know for the oracles
just have them flash once instead of
twice like
little changes like that um to just pick
up the pace of the encounter make it
more punishing so you mean mechanics
changes yeah just like
light mechanic changes doesn't have to
be anything groundbreaking
that's what they used to do four
conflicts is to defend instead of three
you know you would love king's fall
seriously
like yeah that is you would be in your
bag right now yeah
yeah well yeah like any small changes
contest power so it doesn't involve the
artifact i think would be really healthy
for the game
um and i think they have a huge
incentive problem in master vog
um like the gatekeepers challenge
i released a guide for that on youtube
and um
so many people came in like oh my god we
couldn't just we like we tried for
hours and hours could not get this done
that's the hardest thing in destiny like
i have so many comments of just
endless things like that um and i think
a lot of it just comes down to like
you literally just turn a corner and you
follow like your character just
dissolves because your
30 power under your weapons are 30 power
under the 1350 cap
um it just seems so artificially hard
that people get in there they'll
complete it once and then they'll go
farm normal templar fill up on spoils
and come back and purchase multiple
versions of
the adept weapon for that week i i don't
think time getting the weapon drops is
healthy
and i don't and i think it shows an
incentive problem if your players are
going to do
it once and then immediately go back to
the normal version
farm-up spoils and then come purchase
additional versions of the weapon that
they earned
just doesn't seem like a healthy
design to me um i would love to see
you know uh
adept armor drop like there's literally
no reason to go through an entire master
version
do the pit treatment like they they have
such good ideas in this game it just
seems inconsistent between activities
like
the the anarchy drop rate fix they did
that and then eyes of tomorrow's bugged
for
six months right and then it takes the
eyes of tomorrow yeah
yeah and they didn't fix it yeah and
it's like
i i just wish they would be more
consistent if in the in the master
version
one of the things i thought would be
really cool imagine you have
an 11th or maybe even a 12th power slot
for your mods
or just make the raid mods free like
that would that's such a small change
but is the incentive to
actually go through and like try and
farm that armor out
um if you want it to be valuable
everywhere
do do 11 mod slot power or
do the 14 guaranteed base stats like
they do from pitt
so many people go farm people dude i
have been i i'm sorry
like oh my god you are so in my head
because i've been saying
i because like my biggest thing right
now armor is useless
all armor you're getting right now is
just the same stuff over and over and
over and over
it's like oh here's the stat it's like
even like zer or high stat rolls or
spiky and i see people tweet about them
i'm like
it helps but it doesn't change the game
it doesn't change your builds your
loadouts you're still stuck at 10.
and if you're gonna go do a master
difficulty you're like oh i got a high
stat rule
cool it's not like hey this thing
started with a base of 80. people would
be like oh i just lost my mind i have to
go get this 80 stat rule now it's like
no
or this thing has 12 13 14 energy i can
use a lot more mods or beefier mods
things of that nature so even like one
to two does such a big
thing for the hardcore players because
now you can slot a scavenger mod
and you can slot an oracle disrupter
like that's so small
yeah and like most people aren't gonna
notice it but the hardcore players will
notice it you know just give them
something to chase
and then in terms of the weapons being
locked
i mean i guess that's fine if they fix
the incentive issues for every other
encounter
but i don't like the time getting nature
of it and i don't like that you can
repurchase
for spoils because it just completely
uh negates the need to go back and farm
master rays which should be like the
pinnacle thing you go and farm we
literally farm grand masters
all the time like people are just living
that playlist and then masters you're
gonna touch
once for the rotating weapon and you're
never gonna touch it again
and i i that's unfortunate because it's
a really cool addition to the game but
they're just not
there's no reason to run it back so um i
think if you
got rid of the spoils chest or made it
significantly more expensive
and made it so that you had to spend a
separate type of like master spoils on
it
um then i think you might have something
there but i don't know i just the d1
version when you were incentivized to go
back and actually grind
you know your clears every week and and
get those weapons the god rules i feel
like it's so easy now because now they
have curated roles like the curated
fatebringer
is literally firefly explosive so first
try it's like uk well you're done
farming you know you might go for like
an explosive frenzy roll or something
but
it's just gonna be that quick loop and
then people are done with the activity
which i don't think is necessarily
super healthy so travis you have
discerning eyes i'm very curious which
you have to you have thoughts do you
have any thoughts about master rewards
i mean i do and i think all the points
that above made are great
it's just hard for me as a pb player pvp
player to look over at the pve landscape
and hear you guys complain about not
having rewards
okay i want the same thing it's not that
they don't have rewards it's that
they could be structured so much better
and and as as a as a sweat lord like the
rest of you guys
grandmasters are so they're they're
not worth it to me like i've done a
bunch of them and i'm just like alright
yeah this is like
30 minutes of me focusing on killing
enemies that i could have killed
uh super easily in a regular strike but
because it's grand master
arbitrarily they're super powerful uh
and then the reward is that i get like a
slightly better version of a weapon not
worth it for me
and trials has the same problem where
the the stuff you get out of trials
we've talked about this on this show a
bunch which is just like it's not
it's not worth the the effort versus
payoff uh so i 100 agree with you
it's more that like i haven't had a map
in two years you know what i feel like
i'm over here i'm like starving and
like you know give him a cracker at
least so that that's why i was laughing
i was just smiling because i was just
thinking myself like
these guys they just got they got new
activities
they got a remastered raid and then they
got a master version on top of it and
i'm over here
starved to death you know but but
whatever
clips for the fourth yeah yeah but it's
like the same thing would
should apply to things like trials or if
they ever fix competitive be like
hey if you're in diamond rank or however
if they ever get to something like that
have a depth levels of armor as you said
a little bit more space in the energy
slot
little higher stat rules that are like
you know their high version of a stat
rule is like 57 above and it just makes
me laugh when everybody knows like if
it's not like 6162
if it says five no yeah so like if they
took something
and if they took something to be like
hey now it's 70 because then if
70 something was distributed over the
course of this you might be like hey
it's not
perfect but i was like there's a little
bit more here to work with and it could
set it apart just one or two energy
higher tier of stat world to be like
this is something
better and i think i listened to datto
put a good video about
some of this stuff and like he comes
from a world of warcraft background i
know i do but the idea is
like if you do medium tier stuff you can
get medium to your things we can do all
this
basic level stuff right now you're like
hey i go do crucible
you could randomly get a piece of armor
that's actually got a pretty good stat
rule on it
but then you can go get the same thing
from a raid and those two or trials and
those
should not equate if you do the high
level stuff your rewards truly need to
be set apart like
you know if you get a time lost
fatebringer what if the range the reload
speed that stuff was higher above if you
got a
desperado you know an adept desperado uh
messenger
there i know they're always worried
about the pvp and the pve balance and i
know that's where that whole argument
comes back to
but that type of crazy difficult stuff
the juice has to be worth the squeeze
and right now i'm with you like it's not
so yeah yeah it's it's tough too because
i i honestly
so one of the things travis that you
were talking about like the pvp side
i actually tweeted about this literally
yesterday i was talking to you
how cool would it have been if like say
next season
which could potentially be a six month
season we have no idea leading up to
launch of witch queen what if you
sustain like you want to build
pvp hype and get people back into the
trials playlist
bring back two maps like i know asking
for a bunch of new maps is
a tall ask obviously like they're
struggling to get them out for whatever
reason so
bring back two fan favorites from d1 if
you're able to produce two maps
one on europa would be really cool
it would be nice and imagine you get no
information about that
leading up uh ahead of time to trials
and then they debut
one map every week for a month in the
trials playlist
and you just go in and you play the map
for literally the first time
that would build so much hype people
would get so excited to go in there and
you add a new weapon on top of it i feel
like
so many people would jump back into the
playlist and then
you know obviously there's like the
cheating issue and that sort of thing
completely separate
but i feel like that would be so much
healthier and actually like
give pvp players something to like be
excited about and have a healthy
population again at least for a little
while
um yeah it just says something about me
earlier when you were talking about your
history with gaming you said that you
were like
semi-pro at call of duty so you have
that competitive side
clearly you've got the trigger fingers
to do comp and then you play pve
on destiny and i think that says a lot
about destiny's pvp support
yeah if you're if you kind of have those
roots as a pvp player
and destiny has like kind of pushed you
back into the pve side of things so yeah
uh
yeah i think you're right like the we we
are the stepchildren
cog and i uh the forgotten step children
living underneath the stairs that's us
on the pvp side
harry potter if you will yeah yeah
it's tough the letter from my owl got
lost in the mail but yeah
it's just all tragedy my whole life
hagrid has not made it to your house to
break down the door yet either he has
not
he's not no one sorry we went deep on
the harry potter there for a second
that was harry potter
in this game i really do like the
gunplay and destiny i think it's the
reason so many people play and
i think the thing with destiny's always
been you see the potential on the tip of
the fingertips and they just
it you just can't quite grasp it it's
like right there but something's just
slightly off or they're just missing the
mark just a little bit
and i think that's why you have such a
passionate fan base of people who
get frustrated because it is like such a
special game at its core
in the way it feels and the movement and
the the abilities and everything and
then you have you know
titans sliding through walls getting
over shields and you can't kill anybody
in christmas it's like get
him get him talk to him
i love this game to death and uh i hope
pvp gets the love it deserves
and uh yeah i i honestly one change i
would love to see across the board
would be adept weapon reworks because
right now i don't think they're
they're worth it i think in the mode
that they are in
uh so like vault of glass for example
similar to how the d1 weapons operated
they should have intrinsic perks in the
raid
trials should be the same way as an
intrinsic perk not
a column perk that you have the option
to select
i mean but that's a technical limitation
right
what's that oh yeah remember that i
remember that
always that uh create your own weapon
idea i had for trials i still stand by
that it would work
pick your person doesn't make sense
though is like they do that on exotics
that's where i'm like couldn't we not
just build it into the fiber of the guns
themselves
that's what i don't know that kind of
goes deeper into the discussion of
there's this always discussion well the
engine or things are updated in the
background it's like when you
i stream this yeah i was like and i
screamed this when i read it like
cog and i were sitting here in one of
these and i don't even remember the
guest at the time but it was
when i read that i was like oh you just
told me guns are stuck till you
change like deep deep levels of the game
or you put a three on it
because if you're like hey too many
things can't work or if there are too
many modifiers on or whatever
one of them stops working i'm like okay
that means the game is stuck
and that's what's unfortunate hey like
cog and i said if they want to fix it
they just have to start selling the
depth weapons in eververse man then all
of a sudden
all this tech wouldn't want to do it
here
oh you want to buy that oh eververse for
20
000 for twenty thousand silver you can
unlock that new mod slot for all weapons
and armor but it just costs
one a one-time upgrade charge and we
still love you
we are just giving you a really hard
time right now we ain't putting that in
the universe now
don't give them no ideas tessa's she's
moving out here we don't
give any type of ideas they didn't put
that watermarked armor
into uh into the game so they haven't
fully
taken advantage of oh man yes
i kind of wanted to get your thoughts
because i mean i've been seeing master
i thought had our thoughts about
grandmasters and then say you you
spend pretty good amount of time in
there you definitely deep into the high
level stuff to hear you even say as it's
something you do but the rewards aren't
worth it it's kind of good to hear from
somebody who's like hey you don't really
play grandmasters why do you have an
opinion about him it's like well i can
look from afar and it's like
i don't sound too different from some of
the people who do it all the time either
it's like that's kind of nice to hear
now everybody has different opinions but
somebody who's you know doing grand
masters and master vlogs and doing it
all the time it's nice to know that
we're not alone
i mean it's just you know it's one of
those things i i
hope gets you know reworked and
you get players excited because i think
most of the time like you you go to help
somebody and it's just
like next week for example it's going to
be conflux's challenge
right at the start of the raid there's
no shot i'm doing
full master triple help clear like
trying to slog through the whole thing
especially when the weapon you get is
confluxes and that if they want to spend
their spoils at the end of the raid
you check point the end of the raid yep
that's true i mean
that's how the game's designed right now
so yeah that's you know it's unfortunate
but
hopefully they uh hopefully they turn it
around well do you guys want to talk
about reputation and ranks
yeah you guys know sure
hold on travis has an opinion what's up
man no no
go ahead you're just gonna i don't want
to talk about it we go around here
this conversation let's get it i'll be
back in like 20 just you know send me a
text when we're done
uh so over the last few seasons we've
been looking to create a unified
experience when playing ritual
activities in destiny 2.
if you guys are not watching the video
travis just took a nap
we did some back end work at the start
of season 14 in preparation for a larger
scale changes to these reputations
also preparing for the introduction of
vanguard ranks
vanguard ranks are going to work very
similar to the way gambit
and crucible ranks work right now so in
season 15
um the names infamy and valor are going
away
so they're just going to be gambit ranks
crucible ranks and
vanguard ranks glory will live on
so your competitive playlist is still
going to be the mess that it still is
uh trials ranks are going to be a thing
we're going to hear about
i don't even know what to think about
that so before i go any farther
trials ranks um for the pvp half of this
podcast you guys have an opinion about
do you want your uh you know your your
un
what are the upgrade modules and then
your prisms
and your cores and then only on the
first time do you want to get that shard
and then everything else is
do you want those ranks for trials guys
uh
travis has something to say about this
i'm gonna let him go first you're
chomping at the bit here
how are we feeling no
just no this is like
the epitome of bunge or like destiny's
really awful design like their their
reward system right now and this is like
them
i get that they're streamlining it but
really they should be turning the
the car around and driving the opposite
direction because there's
there's this like ongoing debate of like
how much
should be done through bounties or how
much should be done through
uh you know these these season passes
where you're seeing the xp
meters go up and you're getting rewards
like that and
and their their their solution so far
has been oh they'll be these these nice
little
repeatable things but they're they're
basically just you know
you leveling up it's not like it doesn't
address the bigger problems you know the
stuff that above was talking about
earlier where the
actual activities aren't rewarding
enough or like are people going to be
playing trials to move up that meter so
they can get the
you know ascendant shard every season
like no that's like obviously not worth
it and it doesn't address the
huge problems with it now do i have a
problem with
them adding a way for me to like
passively earn additional awards and
trials no that like that's
fine it's just that like this is another
currency
you know how i'm always complaining
about currencies reputation meters are
just more currencies their currencies by
a different name
no i'm not having to go and turn in the
tokens but it's the same loop
it's the same like oh we don't know how
what to do with the system so we'll just
like
give you a reason to grind it endlessly
for like rewards that mean nothing
and ironically what you're getting when
you when you
level up that reputation currency is
you're getting more currency
you're getting more currency to infuse
into other stuff oh you got in a senate
short a form of currency
to put into your items it's just it's
such an
insane loop that i i just i
i it's travis travis
so i can't pick up the materials because
i'm always full on prisms and whatever
so you have to come back to the tower to
reset your valor so
i don't do like i'm not gonna like take
the time to delete prism so that i can
then pick up prisms
so that i can then rank up my valor
i joked about this a couple weeks ago
same thing yeah
we were doing a triple master vlog help
so we were helping
three people at once and on the final
phase going into the final conflicts
valor overflowing pops up while i have
the relic i just swiped
and i fell off the cliff with the relic
and we wiped because valor overflowing
took over my stranger
where did that even come from i don't
know like how is that even a thing
um on a more serious note um i
completely agree with travis
the only thing i think they could do to
because i think like one of the things
for trials is approachability
if they set that um reward structure on
a weekly cadence
and offered the adept weapon
with like maybe missing a couple like
key perks so you you know it's not like
the top top version
but they're able to invest time to get a
weapon they're not the best players but
they put in
a certain amount of play time they
should be rewarded
too and especially with like we're
getting at depths and
gm's and we're getting adepts and fog
and we're getting like all these other
places that are much
in my opinion easier to obtain than the
current trials sandbox with
cheaters and i mean it's just it's
littered with people who literally play
pvp 24 7. so
like you know i can get like a team of
players and we can go and go flawless
but it'll even take like
and i play with some pretty good players
so like it'll even take us
you know a couple cards we'll reset a
couple times and then we'll get it but
like i can't imagine the people who just
want to go in and like try a new game
mode have fun
they just get pub stomped in like game
one over and over again
and then they're immediately they're
done without playlist
but if they had a progression loop to
work towards on a weekly basis maybe
working towards
the adept igneous or the adept sword for
the pv side you're telling me they're
not going to
at least get the playlist and like work
towards those rewards
um i see a lot of other games do that
like i know fifa has weekly reward
structures for playing and
other things and i mean i think that
would be pretty healthy to be honest but
obviously things would have to change so
no i was just going to say
i actually really like that idea you
want to know the problem with that
they need to do it everywhere else true
so if they do something like that for
trials like hey this is a grind
there's these weapons if you make it
through rank 5 in
this season you can unlock the first set
of armor and then rank 10's a piece of
like a weapon and then you know it's 15
is a piece of armor
and then if you do that there and you
actually give people stuff they can
grind for the stuff that's harder for
them to typically get
and maybe there's like you know you
could unlock all that stuff in that i
don't know but i was like
then if you leave like just your upgrade
modules and your currencies over at the
other vendors
and all this other stuff isn't touched
then i wonder if now are we going to be
like well now trials is good
and now now i'm not saying trials
doesn't need all the love it can get it
does
definitely do it does and they
definitely do the other thing
i don't think that you need i don't
think you need to do it everywhere and i
don't think you should because
it's one of those things where like if
everything's a priority nothing is
if everything is as rewarding as trials
trials doesn't grow in its player base
and i think
they need to come up with specific ways
to drive
people to these end game activities and
actually make it worth their while so
like grandmaster nightfall
maybe the napmaster raid but especially
trials because trials
pvp has been carrying the longevity of
destiny on its back for
years and it's the reason that people
play it for so long and
the fact that that is one of the least
effective ways to grow in power and to
gain
good loot is horrible like that's it
it used to be the one way that you could
get
uh uh elemental effects on your uh
primary weapon slot like that was huge
it was a reason
everyone like myself was like in there
rabidly every weekend trying to go
flawless and yeah
it's just nothing like that now so i
mean you guys said it
best i mean at the end of the day it's
just like you know they have to do
something to create a gauge i love
above's idea as far as the matching the
you know the weapon or you know pursuit
seasonal pursuit
you know in there because again they've
got to figure out a way to incentivize
the casual this this is what it comes
down to
like you said there's nothing more
demoralizing
than jumping in trials match one pub
stomped right have no hope that you can
even
get any farther and then and then you
bounce so they've got to figure it
out away now it seems to be the theme
seems to be staying in the mode and i
know we're going to get into it more
deeper
with the rest of the stuff but i'm with
travis too like
trials needs that extra bump they need
that extra incentive
so that it's it's actually skewed
towards that it suffered so long i don't
even know what the player
pvp um population numbers are these days
does anybody even know what's going i
mean
the thing that's crazy to me it's not
good like the player population is
very very small um the thing that's
fascinating about trials though is like
even though no one's playing it they
will watch
top tier players play it it's still one
of the most popular
weekly events on twitch you go and watch
frostbolt and he has like
five six thousand viewers on reset
because they want to see what the trials
map is what the loot is you know they
they want to watch high-level gameplay
but they don't want to go in there and
suffer themselves
so if they made it more approachable and
this goes for
everything in destiny they have like
this they need to have like the kind of
like the marathon or sprint
approach to loot and so if you're really
good at the game
you can get the best loot very quickly
or if you invest your time
i feel you you put the time into it you
can get it too you might not get as many
roles or the best version necessarily
but you can still get it you can work
towards it
and that's a healthy game structure to
have but like right now it's just like
okay a new light player you come in you
hear about trials you go in you
you lfg on an out of game lfg which must
have kb
of no yeah that's a whole nother thing
they get pub stomped and then they
become
you know what we call jumping jerry's
which is they just dropped
you know that's a wrap for the week and
it's just not i wish
i don't know there's got to be a better
way got to be a way hey got to be a
better way
it's real though like they've got to
figure that out because at the end of
the day
whatever resources you know that you
need to put
to pull into this you have to and this
boat is just too
prestigious not for it to be treated
with that level of respect as well as
that incentive so
yeah i'm i'm i'm with you guys you know
hopefully we'll see how
how this is going to go where they
announced it right future bob's going to
have a lot of eyes
it's going to be a lot i'm very curious
to see
what they do child's reiki anywho
tangent aside which i knew was gonna
happen but that's why i took the buzz
uh we are rebalancing all ranking
systems have similar progression time
basically they want vanguard crucible
gamer ranks to be slightly faster
on average lets everybody get through
this a little quicker for example gambit
infamy is like 15 000 or 18 or 16 some
stupidly large number
um there will be no longer ritual
specific rules that impede progress
uh their bonus weekends are just going
to be 2x they're removing street bonuses
this is the one i wanted to ask you guys
they're removing street bonuses but in
exchange they're going to do
activity streak bonuses instead of win
streak bonuses
um basically they looked at how long it
takes for players to win
nearly every game saying crucible or
gambit and also lose every game
feels like most people are probably
going to do about do it about twice as
fast
generally an overall improvement is what
it sounds like i would say
um they said glory will continue which
also basically i think means glory will
be addressed later
mostly is what that means um basically
it seems like you will reset a little
bit faster if you win everything but
most people are just going to be
progressing on a similar timeline
in game it's not going to take you six
years which is good
overall doesn't seem like a bad thing
yeah i think it's good i mean it goes
with the same
you know marathon or sprint thing right
like if you lose you're not going to be
punished by
having it take five four times what did
they say three or four times longer yeah
if you win every
so yeah i mean just participate get your
awards i think
that's the main issue with most
playlists so that's a
that's a good change in my opinion right
vanguard ranks these are comments
i agree i agree okay yeah
um shout out to zavala
he's going to be rolling in tokens if
you haven't seen
uh what a tassie had like a 40 minute
video of turning his tokens in
i guess i saw datto in his videos like i
have 9 000 to turn in kill me now that
type of thing
turn your tokens in before the end of
the season you have a month do like 100
a day don't don't just sit there and
kill your finger
just turn in a few clear out the vault
say get your shards if you care or just
don't care and override everything in
the postmaster and just get it over with
just find a macro and walk away
uh but commanders of all is getting a
full reputation justice
reputation system like shacks and
drifter it's going to start in season
15.
uh it's going to be available for
strikes nightfalls and battlegrounds
because battlegrounds are not going to
be sunset at least until which queen
my assumption is they probably will go
away there i know they've said they will
carry through 15 for the reason that
they're still part of that vanguard
structure
but as battlegrounds are part of season
the chosen i don't know how long they're
gonna last i will be curious
how they handle that on a story front uh
they said nightfalls give a bra
a different bonus based on completion
medals so
these will count say if you get like
more champions killed
or higher difficulty you will be getting
more reputation so
above over here farming platinum grand
masters he's gonna have 12 million
vanguard reputation
and more weapons and armor from zavala
and he knows what to do with
it sounds like you know yeah that might
be that might be a thing
would you please do would you please
come to the tower zavala has a message
you have 14 ranks to clear
oh crap um as long as the message
doesn't pop up on my screen and cause a
wife
because
you're gonna have three times as many
opportunities for that to happen
it's gonna be like gambit infamy and
valerie they all win at the same time
oh god um
but yeah he will have a full reputation
line similar to shacks and drifter
powerful rewards will be granted every
third rank and a senate chart will be re
rewarded when resetting the first time
anybody else have an issue with that
last line
the ascended chard if you go through the
rank you get the ascended chart the
first time
after you do the first time it's only an
exotic it never turns into an ascendant
chart again
no matter how many times you fully cycle
that thing yeah that is interesting
choice right
why to to to get that to just
one reset like i don't know what do you
guys think i think i think that's a
little strange travis would you think
it seems yeah i mean it's been a
it's not rewarding man like this yeah
well you want another exotic that you
can get from zurich that you can get
from legend lost sectors that you can
get from doing the activity
here's more exotics like that's the only
thing i feel like sometimes they have
that they can give us
outside of like you know the occasional
adept weapons which we just got done
beating with a dead horse
is here's more exact yeah here's more
armor
or an ascendant shard like at least you
could give both
yeah if somebody goes and grinds like 60
000 strikes to go through and they've
done
oh they did ten ranks they got five
shards that means they could do two
normal pieces of armor and one exotic
like it's not like they're swimming in
shards if they're just living in the
strike playlist but they get one
they can change the elements on one
piece of masterworked armor yeah
that's the most expensive thing in
destiny right now is changing the
element on an armor
especially if this is an exotic it like
drains you dude it tastes like
everything what do you have nothing
like i said i shot out above i was in
there all my vlog
turned to to devoid as soon as i seen
his video
and i wasted bad resources to do it
because i was like i need
because i had the the the uh the raid
bar but i just they had a correct
elevator that's literally all i'm doing
with these
resources and yeah it's weird like i
don't know why they're so
ridiculous with shaw it's like i know
especially think about this for the for
again the casual the new player right
like this guy that i'm
trying to tell him what to do in destiny
and stuff like that there's not a lot of
resources for that you know so you know
why not
like why why are we they want us to live
in the activity
but they don't want to reward the same
first path for living in it
like i don't i don't get it it's bizarre
i don't
i mean i literally get comments on my
videos how do i get ascendant charts
like i think i've had that same comment
like five or six times and i'm just like
it's either well it's either time oh
yeah it's either
time which we'll get to towards the end
of this podcast
from like the season pass and stuff or
as you said the hardest stuff that like
the average solo player is like
i'm sorry what i have to do what yeah so
yeah there's not a ton
try explaining a grand master nightfall
to a casual player of destiny
it's such a bizarre like even idea for
an event do you know the strikes that
you do
like when you're still learning to play
the game well
they made one where you have to grind to
be the maximum level it takes weeks and
weeks to do
and then when you get there uh every
single enemy kills you in like two hits
and you have to heavily research a a
an asinine meta to like put up barriers
as the titan or
whatever is the strap for that strike so
that you can get one gun that's a little
better right then we got to use the head
glitch like that above said
exactly exactly
so travis are these rewards really good
that sounds like a lot of work
no so so the funny thing about it is
that not only are they not good
but then if you want to fully upgrade
those rewards you get
you have to do you have to use a
currency that you get by doing
more grand master nightfalls how does
that sound
yeah you want to play is final fantasy
set
14 back on sale yet yeah
or a thought instead of farming the gm's
over and over again for that depth on
jury just go play the new light mission
and get like a perfect night watch
that's just way better in everything
so as noted above season 15 we'll
introduce
activity streaks the longer you stay in
the vanguard activity
uh playlist or direct lunch uh the
larger your streak bonus is
guardians can leave the matchmaking
queue to snag bounties from the tower or
clean out your postmaster from the helm
without losing their streaks as a note
quitting activities or going afk
extended period of time
will invalidate your streak so be ready
to play if you're looking
to keep yours going um as with crucible
and gamut zavala will be looking to host
week-long reputation bonuses throughout
the season
stay tuned for in-game announcements so
before we get to anything else
thoughts on the activity streaks travis
is about to bite his finger off it looks
like
above go first i was just gonna say
i think it's a i i'm i'm fine with it
there better be rewards tied to it
that's all i'm gonna say like the
right now it's reputation that's that's
what you get on the game show that i do
which is grand master gauntlet we delete
oh god rolls right the one weapon i
refuse
to touch no matter what normally
nothing's off limits you're like 100 000
charity option nope
no yeah like you could donate so many
like the royal entry god roll that i
have i have
like the impact casing auto loading
lasting impression
and that thing is so hard to get
because it has a million perks it
doesn't drop very often
um and so i just refuse to touch that
weapon because i'm like i
will probably never get this forget that
again yeah um
if you have the activity streak bonus
you should get a significant
multiplier on the drop rates of the
activity specific loot so like the empty
vessel which is actually
really good and so is uh so is
royal entry i would love if they would
do something like that i hope they
i hope they've thought about that and
like do that and reward players for it i
am worried
that that's not gonna be the case but um
yeah i i i'm fine with the activity
shrieks as long as they actually provide
benefit to the player because a lot of
that loot's pretty rare right now
don't get your hopes up
that's the unfortunate part you already
know like right
they're like what are you getting more
reputation what does that give me i go
through the ranks again
like nothing levels yeah like
unfortunately for what you just said
that sounds actually like oh hey if more
you spend more time in this playlist him
on my 10th strike
what are your chances of getting a
weapon every strike like 90
that'd be awesome as opposed to just
garbage
most of the time uh travis you had an
opinion
he has to gather his gather himself a
playlist
that rewards you for staying in it
more you guys know that uh
you guys remember that that arc from
game of thrones
where uh uh theon greyjoy
gets captured by ramsey snow yeah and
he's like slowly wearing away his
yes yes yeah this would be stop holding
him you're going to stockholm syndrome
is where you're killing
breaking him and breaking him and
breaking him that i feel like is what
bungie's been doing to us
all these years just slowly like getting
us more and more like
like we're like the the abused spouse
that just can't leave you know
and and this right now this is
this playlist is them telling us to
shave them you know that
scene where he's like my face
and and and reek is just like yes sir it
doesn't
think about it that's what that's what
this playlist is to me it's like this
it's we we we just spent this whole show
and like
anybody who plays destiny complains
about it it's like our our national past
time as like a community because we love
the game but we
kind of are victims of stockholm
syndrome uh and there's just that funny
relationship but
i everybody has this sort of
conversation and then we see a move like
this that's just like yeah
and now you're gonna stay in it even
longer and we're going to give you guys
incentives to not
leave us it's like they're just putting
out their hand and being like kiss my
ring
that's what it is
i'll be i'm at his bleakest traffic
look on one hand i get it because i got
a lot of casual friends
and like for example addicts one of my
guys he's turned into a casual dusty
player now he's like i just
he's been beaten down enough he's like
i'm just gonna jump in
i'll do my tuesday tune in next week
what's gonna happen with the story on
reset
and he loves strikes though he loves
strikes
so this will actually appeal to him
right
he's gonna stay in there he's gonna get
rewards he's gonna get blessed for that
and he doesn't care about pvp you know
what i'm saying
he doesn't you know again but he's okay
he used to like him but that's where
he's at so
on one hand i like it because if you
love
a specific of the three tenets the holy
trinity
that's the view and pvp
you're gonna get rewarded on the other
hand i do see what travis is talking
about where it's like
forced engagement this is for the free
to play players to fill their their
play right right basically like this is
for
this is again for a person who's casual
that just want to do that one thing
it's going to serve its purpose but it
it is interesting
the way the mechanic works where it's
like yo if you leave
yeah it's like funny it's like somebody
gives you something to eat and you taste
it and you're like oh my god it tastes
like crap can i have another one
maybe if i eat ten more it'll start
tasting good like that's like
grinding the same strikes over and over
again isn't good and they're like well
maybe if we
give you an incentive where you like you
have to do it for a bunch to get certain
rewards then maybe it'll leave a good
taste in your mouth it's like what is
that
logic what they're gonna do is i don't
know if i'm too ahead yeah i'm too ahead
i will get to the ritual weapon thing
but
i i know what they're gonna try to do to
it yeah us which we'll get into
right but for now for the casual guy
i get this a lot they'd be like yo what
do i need to do how do i level up
faster this is going to appeal to them
and news flash this is a casual game
majority of the time yeah with the
engagement in the numbers
and i know i know travis i know i know
it burns your soul i understand
i i feel you you know say they still
have to do something for
us because we look at that and we go
oh no no no i see what you're doing you
try to watch me in this prison of
something i don't want to do all the
time
i just want to mention someone who
enters the strike playlist and just
plays it for fun like for three hours
bro that's addict i'm actually
no i know i know people are mad people
that do this
i know what people who live in gambit
they're just having fun
and then they're getting a little
rewarded though because there's a
there's a win
lose like strike only has one outcome
which is you win and once you've
played it especially if you've played it
two or three times you've experienced
everything that strikes gonna offer so
what do you get on the 10th 11th 12th
time are you getting out of it
i think it just comes down to destiny
just feels good for people to play like
they just enjoy
shooting aliens in the face like that in
face yeah
and a lot honestly as someone who does a
lot of guides for endgame content i have
to remind myself of that a lot
of like i can't just recommend the same
meta weapon or subclasses or whatever
every single time even though like
anarchy preaching clear
you know what i mean but uh like yeah
you just you have to take a step back
and like think about
there's just the majority like like
uh lord cognato said it's just like a
lot of people are
super incredibly casual even more than
like
we may even realize like they literally
like as you said
play the mission which like i don't even
keep up with that stuff
um and then they do a couple strikes and
then they
you know they log off and that's what
they do how to get though
that i get like a short term yeah i'm
just saying like the people who
like they they log on loyally literally
one in chat
like ducky
he's like it's just like i'll run
strikes for four hours he said it's just
some great vibes like
is it just to hang out with people
you got a little net like a lot of
people like
a little bit of a narrative component
right so each one is these little
self-contained stories now granted yeah
they're going to repeat and after a
while you're going to run out but
for some people they love that bro i'm
telling you travis
it's more than you think it's fun to
apparently just shoot stuff with your
friends that's what that's true
is that's what they want to do they just
want to hey let's just play let's play
this together man let's just rock out
casual chill and that's what they and
they're perfectly fine
doing that yeah i guess my brain's just
wired differently it's like i get it on
the competitive side because
i'm with but yeah it's like that i'm the
same way
because like i've been doing legend and
master
guides and it's like i'll do a master
lost sector guide but i'm like
i do the same thing it was like i try
and then some people like well i don't
have i'm like okay so i switched and i
was like
no exotics i don't even use my super
basic non-masterwork stuff can i beat
this and i'm like all right
if i can do it this way you guys have
better stuff than i do please use your
good tools but this is how you can do it
without them
like that's and those are some of the
ones that are like thank you this is for
the average old 50 year old person who
doesn't understand all this like
old young person talking i'm like okay
somehow i feel old and young at the same
time because i'm helping you but also
so it's weird but like those are the
comments that you see and you're like
yeah there's a pretty good chunk of the
people out there that are looking that
stuff up
yep so it's like every so often you're
reminded that 80 20. we're in the 20 or
smaller
anybody here who's fairly dedicated is
definitely in the
yeah pretty low level but as we
talk about a little more uh they said
next season they're moving the seasonal
ritual weapon
and ornaments to the reputation reward
tracks for vanguard crucible and gambit
so as you work your way through
reputation
instead of getting your seasonal weapon
you have to put time into the playlist
now
as opposed to go check off the
activities i like that a lot actually i
think that's a very good change
because right now it's like you just go
grind
you know assure a cheat checkpoint and
get the weapon in 20 minutes so it's
you know now it's you actually have to
do the activity and engage in it and
earn the cosmetics which is good that's
how it should be that encourages
natural playlist participation not the
fourth stuff like just talking about
locked in a playlist you actually have a
reason to go do it that's that's good
that's how it should be i honestly
i would love to see them bring pinnacle
weapons back
yep that's a hold i mean i know that
would we could go on for
six hours talking about that but like
genuinely
i'm not i swear i'm not going down a
rabbit hole that i'm just saying
no that's what you say right before uh
break it down break it down why why
someone said it needs to come back i
want to hear it
they did in d1 and they did it the right
way in d1 because they gave you
a lot of weapons to chase if they i
think if they had done
sunsetting um now
uh where we have uh season the splicer
and season of the chosen loot
uh where the the
i guess like the weapons you have at
your disposal now is so much more
flooded than it was at the launch of
beyond light where you literally had
like
30 new guns to use total and everything
else was sunset so you there were like
actual archetypes that were completely
just not in the game like they didn't
have
a replacement for the weapon so you're
like well what the hell do i use
now um whereas like now
there's so like you have ignition code
you have truth teller you have so many
other things and then
on top of the issues they had with sun
setting in terms of like replacement
loot
they recycled old loot and brought that
back as a
solve and that's just that was like the
biggest slap in the face i think if they
did
right it's it's very healthy for the
game because power creep is a real thing
the reason we don't use most of the
exotics that we have is because
anarchy and izanagi exist and there's
literally no reason
because they fill so many roles you
should ever use
any other gun ever soul is jumping i
continue
i dude i love this stuff i could i could
literally talk about it
this is literally the last you've
entered the last word now
all right so here's the deal here's the
deal now i got i got this this is the
question he's got to ask
i know where you're going you know where
i'm going you know what i'm going i got
to ask him i gotta ask
because you made some very powerful
statements sir i mean you're very
passionate about it you know
um i do think that you have some valid
points in reference to power creep
um still being an issue and even though
they
onset you know sunsetting whatever they
did right but
now they're gonna cause power creep yeah
right now the question becomes the
exotics right that's been a little bit
of point of contention here
so my question to you is are you cool
right with them saying okay you know
what after next season
anarchy's done you know power level is
added to max or whatever it is
you can't go any further with it and
slowly
uh remove those from from from the pool
and
and either introduce new stuff or not
like where
where are you at with exotics
specifically i think they should be
sunset as well
and i'll tell you why let's go
if you don't if you can take like
literally
every future raid will suffer from the
same issue the same exact the same exact
incentive problems we've been discussing
all day long yep
you ever want another exotic to be
powerful you're going to have to make it
better than izanagi's and anarchy
and wither horde and divinity and all
these other incredible exotics that we
have in the game right now
you're gonna have to make it so good
that it it
supersedes those and so if you do that
pretty soon
like in which they're not going to make
something better than current state
anarchy they're just not
like look at vex mythic class no one
cares about the exotic because it's not
like there's no reason to run it there's
no reason to run an exotic primary
there's no i mean that you can go down
the list of like incentive issues right
it's because those guns exist
if they didn't exist and they were
sunset and then you could take them into
the strike playlist that they want to
keep you in and you can use them and
have a blast
maybe incentivize you even more to go
grind the casual playlist because you
can use all your old favorite weapons
that don't have a power level
restriction
then maybe you have something but until
they do that like the witch queen
raid could come out with a pretty good
exotic
but is it going to top anarchy and if it
doesn't is anybody going to care about
it
i don't think so and that's because sun
setting isn't a thing
and it's it's literally healthy for the
game i think if they expanded the window
from a year which one of the major
issues was okay
deep stone crypt just dropped if i get
this weapon dropped now and i farm all
these spoils
over and over again i'm gonna be able to
use a witch queen that was not the case
when dsc dropped
because it launched in november they
sunset
uh a year after and so technically if
you performing it at the beginning
those weapons wouldn't have been usable
for the witchcrane raid so
i think if you expand it to like 18
months it gives it a nice life cycle you
carry on to the next major expansion you
use those on the day one raid race
and then that next season those retire
and you have a reason to farm the newest
raid for the best endgame loot
um and it just it would continue a
healthy cycle of like okay
my old stuff is going i can use it in
this raid so i have a reason to grind it
but then once that's over i have to go
grind new stuff i think that's really
healthy
i mean it's a definition of a looter
shooter you want to chase
loot but i think that's a huge problem
for most people right now because
people are literally just farming
templar to go by anarchy and then that's
all they use
because it's so good or or izzy or you
know any of the other overpowered
exotics because there's just
not a reason to use anything else
no no i mean look i'm never gonna
disrespect what above is saying in
reference to power creep
you know that's a real thing and i did
say
once i he knows i was actually surprised
they reverse course on sun setting
right because the points they made yeah
there were some value they were valid
points there you know power creep
you know and to me i always looked at it
as
we got to figure out from me being
bungee like we got to figure out a way
for them to stop using mountain time for
recluse
we made these things a little bit too
powerful mountaintop recluse and revoker
i think if those would have just been
sunset they would have solved half of
their worries
and they had to figure out a way right
the legendary part i'm there
i i've i've acquiesced on that part he
knows right
i'm okay with the legendary part because
i get it it's just
so many weapons and there's so many in
the same archetype but then it just
comes down to
at some point you're just going to
establish you know the meta stuff
and i get that i get that you get a
fresh you know new coat of paint and new
weapons come in
okay cool i'm okay with that and i'm
actually cool what you said
with the um the length the length of
time right
that being extended a bit i'm cool with
that the reason why i struggle
with exotics is too far apart one
you know i'm saying like again as far as
the introduction of them
into the game it's not in the same
cadence of legendaries that's one yeah
two the the thing is i still feel like
even though this is a lunar shooter game
and and
the goal is to get loot i feel it's
personally disrespectful to the player
to say hey i'm gonna make you go through
pressage and do all this stuff
right and you're gonna get this dead
man's tail i'm gonna make you go through
the raid and you're gonna bleed sweat
and tear like my man
travis to try and 18 months isn't long
enough to enjoy it
let me feel it to try for the hope
of getting an eyes of tomorrow right for
the hope
right some of these exotics are rng like
the rain ones stuff like that
and to me it does feel
disrespectful to that person's
engagement
for the exotic part and my only counter
to it would be just say okay
if you're gonna do that and if you're
gonna say
we're going to sunset and cool then
my request that he knows it's like can
you give me a new engine
can you give me the thing you want
enough fresh in this so you don't want
it
fresh you freshen up this uh dedicated
server
you you freshen you put a maybe a three
on it you come up with some narrative
beat like you did in d2 and say the
tower blew up and they robbed us
or whatever they did that's all i want i
just want
structurally the game to also improve
because again
i know people who either a never
got anarchy or they missed out and then
there's no chance for them to ever again
so i think we're pretty much the same
i'm just i know he's about to go
can i ask you one question on say the
specific rate exotics because you've
mentioned
anarchy yeah mentioned eyes of tomorrow
yes
if there was a specific way to go after
those instead of hey it's an rng drop at
the end of the raid
right hey this is a quest that you build
to you
build the weapon you acquire pieces or
keys or eyes
from or all these little parts from the
raid to have a direct path that
eventually like hey i gotta run the raid
three times
maybe i have to do a couple things while
we do it
some specific tasks to acquire that
weapon so if you know you have a direct
path to it
then you have a much shorter window
i was gonna say not travis rng
for 50 weeks or something stupid like
right
i'm going to be brutally i know where
you're going i'm a brutal honest
i don't think i've ever said this so
last before i think about
i don't like quest exotics i agree what
i agree i don't like them i hate it i
hate all i have to do is distort
admission and i'm
guaranteed to me it devalues it
i also don't like at the start of the
season here comes the battle pass
log in i hate that too trust me i hate
both of those things
i like d1 the exotics
being rare exotics really i don't like
big showered in it
so to me it's just a direct pat i don't
like the direct pat i'm gonna be honest
i never liked it i just never already
said it
yeah okay i'll be direct yeah it's like
if exotics are something you have to go
through and earn
through a difficult activity you don't
like pressage
i like the mission i just i to me i
always been a fan
of the rng with exotics okay
i've been afraid have you just been like
have you just been
like lucky on all exotics and never been
to a point where like
hey i'm nine months into destiny 1 and i
finally got my first gal horn like
was that never you where you're like i
am beyond frustrated that like
nothing nothing i can do i didn't mind
it to be to me that
to me that's part of the lure of destiny
the jealousy
you're like damn he got that choice
because i'm on i
i always have bad luck so i'm on the bad
side of this equation
always but i also just have a
philosophical disagreement but
i get it to me it's it's it's it's that
guardian formal when you look at your
man you like like
listen to me i think there's a fun i
know this gonna sound really crazy i'm
about to say it's travis i'm so sorry
i think there's a fun when we do the
rain right
and everybody's looking at that atheist
and only one person got a gold icon on
they screen
and the rest of them and it says ippon
just at the ball
like to me it's funny like i i think
there's
at the end of it 50 times i guess is the
issue with that
exactly i read it i'll finish my phone
i'll give it right back to you above
granted well i love what they did is say
okay we got to put
some protection so each time you run it
the percentage increases okay
so that metric metric so then how is
that different than a quest
yes how is that different a small
percentage okay
how many times okay are you okay with do
you want to run into 50
it's a small percentage okay again 20
would be fair
because like i don't know you still
there
you're collecting 20 of atheon's heads
that's your quest like
that's the same thing then it's just a
quest yeah if you
want a time limit on it you're saying
hey you've got to go through and acquire
20x times all you're doing is 20
completions and checking a box as
opposed to
what if i would see i would rather have
it to where if i go through and do the
raid it's like hey you've got to kill
atheon while using a void subclass or
using an ark subclass like
or some dumbass weird list of stuff
where you've got to go through and do
hey do it with different weapons or
however destiny can find a way to make a
quest but something that's not just like
if you hit the box of 20 you get your
thing that's just
what's the difference of i just do it
and you get it like
to me so i agree they shouldn't they
shouldn't be handouts congratulations
that's the one right like where i don't
know it's the quests that are so
easy that they're not memorable like for
me lament was actually pretty cool
because it had like its own story unique
storyline to it
whisper the world i'm all for this oh of
course like any of those beautiful
absolutely like please continue to do
that but when it's you know
they're handed down the seasons pass or
yeah
and then you get you know like that that
stuff is just so
and i think that and so i agree
everybody with 20
shouldn't get the new seasonal exotic at
the beginning and then it's just it just
is irrelevant because everybody has it i
agree with that i think the problem
behind rng
is that you just have these guys with
dumb luck these schmucks walking around
with uh
exotics when somebody like me has done
it 50 times and still not gotten it
and i don't think that that is
it's not a super great ecosystem
especially if one of those weapons is
the meta
and it's also just not a good feeling
from a game design perspective so i
think they should do
both if i were creating the loot system
and destiny there would be a two or
three percent chance of you getting an
exotic
through a natural means like beating a
raid and if you go through the whole
raid
at the end you'd get your your drop
chance but there would also be
a really difficult optional challenge
you could do
to get it to drop to force it to drop
because there are some people who
maybe consider themselves high skill and
maybe value their time and have other
stuff they could be doing
and don't want to have to do 50 uh raids
to the point where they hate the raid we
were talking about this before the show
but like i hate deep stone crypt now
because i was forced to do it
week after week for almost a full year
and
just to get the eyes of tomorrow again i
have never fired right
because i needed it on my checklist um
and and now i
i'm upset with that raid i just think
that there should be
a super high threshold for the people
who want to like do that optional
and force it and then also a low chance
for the people who just get
with laughter that's fine they can have
travis what if what if uh
what if this is crazy idea but what if
it automatically dropped when you beat
all of the master challenges
in what right what or what what it what
if it automatically dropped when you got
a day one
challenge mode clear like i did on deep
stone crypt
dude i beat it on day one on the
challenge mode and then they told me
oh yeah but somebody else who beat it
the next day got eyes of tomorrow and i
had to do it 52 more times
i'm pissed about that dude bro i'm
always going to be on your side travis
when it comes to
you just said it was funny to watch him
i know i
love i think it's hilarious i think it's
loud
meta for me personally when the raids
come out that's just to say this
i think it's funny but at the end of the
day i do agree
that if he's doing a harder version of
it
then those chances should significantly
increase to almost guarantee him that i
i agree with that
because that again we always talk about
reward incentive like
like you said he like for you to be in
there
there needs to be substantial rewards
kind of thing but
that's just where i'm at with it but e
continue because i'm dying to hear you
i just think there's a i think there's a
middle ground between giving it to
everyone
and locking it behind just rock solid
rng that means that people like me could
just do it forever and never get it
there's got to be
a space in between of yeah 20 normal
clears
a vog or five master and you're
guaranteed it and
it can drop any time between that point
but at least it's rng protection you're
not literally just like
well hopefully i'm not running this for
the next six months
and you know doing three clears a week
that are time gated and i can't do
anything about that
but 20 basically is six months
i mean not not across characters if it's
account based but yeah okay well
not everybody has all three characters
so it can it could be six months for one
person
but then that's getting into i think 20
is too much because by 20 you hate the
raid
if you hate the raid you've done it too
many times yeah
that's fair but five would be if you
have three characters you you're
guaranteed it weak too
which for vlog would be really good i
mean maybe like 10's the sweet spot i
don't know
there is something to be said about
though like really rare exotics
especially like dude i remember
dropping from last wish it was like it
was such a big deal because at the time
i don't know if you guys remember it was
the uh
the frame rate issue so oh yeah yes that
thing was so broken
damaged it was it was busted so
everybody wanted it
and like you definitely you need that
aspirational loot in destiny i know that
rng is not the best way to do it but
at the end of the day that's like what
keeps the hardcore players coming back
to
games like wow and final fantasy yeah
maybe i don't know maybe you tie it to
cosmetics i i don't know
how you do it in a healthy way it's it's
hard like i don't
think anybody has a perfect answer for
it i think uh
so to get back to what you guys were
talking because i definitely wanted to
talk about the sun setting thing yes
i actually agree with above for the most
part i i was a guy who when they not
sunsetting i said on fire team chat like
yeah this is good like they there should
be a thing and then destin you know said
no
famously and and now he feels vindicated
that they took it out
but the thing is the reason sun setting
didn't work is because they didn't
live up to the promise that they made oh
you're right yeah absolutely right they
were going to try new things
and they were going to uh have weapons
that were broken but then you know they
only stayed there for a little bit of
time and
and all that stuff and what they ended
up doing was selling you the same
weapons
that they had just sunset you just
re-earned them in a new season
and not really doing a lot of
experimentation and kind of still being
gun shy about having broken weapons and
i think that's the reason that system
did work it had nothing to do with the
philosophy behind it
that said i think that sunset
sunsetting has always existed and it
still exists in destiny
it just got rebranded now it's called
nerfs now it's called patches now it's
called
updates but it's still the same thing if
they nerf an exotic into the ground so
that it's no longer part of the meta
that is a sunset if they are reducing
people's arc type damage for
uh machine guns have been sunsetted on
pve for a while for example and cannons
yeah ham cannons just got a a downgrade
for for some of those so like
they're able to control the meta by
doing sunsetting they just got rid of
the term sun setting and now
everybody's okay with it but sunsetting
has always existed
and it exists on exotics they they sense
that exotics
i just think that um i i mean no no
finish i'm sorry
i was just gonna say i just think that
like the the
you know you guys were saying oh if they
just took those seasonal weapons out the
the recluse then it would have solved
all the problems and i think that that
is probably mostly true but it also just
the the whole idea behind taking away
stuff that you've already earned oh
you're taking away my accomplishments
i just don't buy it man they're taking
away your accomplishments no matter what
because
there's the whole creep of the power
system your power is always going up
there's the whole
they're giving you a slightly better
version and even if even if it's power
creep they're still
essentially invalidating your stuff even
stuff like grandmaster dude the
grandmaster
strikes the grandmaster nightfalls is
sort of an invalidation of your entire
power journey because they just make the
bosses
all the enemies 20 power higher than you
it's like this whole game of like oh
we're respecting your decisions but
ultimately we can't really make them
matter because if they mattered
you would just be able to blow through
all the content and none of this would
would matter to you like nothing would
be a challenge so
i just think they should do
because they already do seasonal
artifacts and seasonal mods there should
be seasonal weapons
too ones that are specifically marked as
this is going to go away at the end of
the season
not all of the weapons but some of them
the ones that they know are
really very reckless now they could drop
those in why not just make seasonal
weapons if they're really worried about
it and then
weapons and then you know you know you
know when you get
them you know when you get them that
it's only going to be temporary because
that seems to be everybody's problem of
like i earned this it's mine and they're
just so entitled and it's just like
okay well then why are they why is it
they take away mods from you with the
artifact they take away your mods you
earned those you grinded for those
why did they take away your power you
grinded for your power every season and
they take it away by just moving the
goal post a little farther so
they're taking away stuff from you all
the time so let's just be transparent
about what we get to keep
and what is permanent and what is going
away and if you're going to nerf stuff
into the ground where it's essentially
sunset
then we like why are we worrying about
the verbiage of whether they call it a
sunset or not that's my that's
i mean it's it's like with anything in
marketing right it's how you
it's how you market it i guess to your
your player base right like what feels
what feels better
anarchy gets sunset because it's too
good like
it's it's such a good weapon you had it
for a year and a half it absolutely
destroyed raid bosses
and then it gets sunset into the vault
and they're able to
come up with newer stuff that's just as
powerful because they don't have
they can replace hopefully that would be
the goal you know they come up with
something cool
that takes the place of that and the
meta versus like
yeah that gun you know and love you
can't use it in strikes anymore in its
current form
we're just gonna gut it and now like
you know that that gun that you once
knew it doesn't actually exist anymore
it's completely changed
if you like i mean you remember og
recluse when it did two and a half times
body damage as well it was insane
when they changed it and then they
nerfed feeding frenzy as well
the gun it was still good but it wasn't
it wasn't done it wasn't the recluse you
knew where you were just like dude i
would use this over my machine gun like
this thing's insane
brad clear um so i don't know part of it
for me is just like how you message it
to your community like i
i would love that year and a half window
you let a gun shine
um you know i mean there's always going
to be nerfs where they're like
holy crap we did not mean for it to be
this time i changed the decimal by one
tenth and i busted it
yeah yeah you know let let things be
powerful for a while and then they have
their time in the limelight and then you
know
they get reverted to just the the base
content you can go use it in strikes and
quick play or whatever like i can still
go use my spare and mind benders and
play and i hold and eagan was saying it
in chat but like i hold on to those
weapons as trophies in my vault even
though they've been sunset i'll never
delete my spare that has
5 000 kills on i never delete my recluse
that has 120 000 kills on it like i
i those are like trophies from things
that i accomplished and i can look back
and be like
man that was fun and sometimes i can go
and take them for a spin if i if i want
to but
i don't know if i'm not really the
biggest fan of nerves
i i agree i'm just i i'm just saying
like
there they are sunsetting things that's
my point is that the name has just
changed and i
i tend to agree like if you're gonna
sunset something just call it sun
setting and be transparent about why
but doing these nerfs are kind of like
to me like ghost sunsetting efforts yeah
they're just saying like oh we're not
sunsetting but then
they're using nerfs to do the exact same
thing that was the purpose of sunsetting
and
i don't think there's another option
power creep cannot exist
we can't get to the point where
destiny's just broken like it was the
season of the drifter that that just
can't
be the way that the game works so you
have to take things away
to keep the game going and make it
balanced and if you have to do that
then we need sunsetting we just need it
and if that comes in the form of nerfs
or you call it sunsetting
it has to exist so why don't they just
call it sunsetting and stick to their
guns like they said they were gonna do
instead of counting reasoning there was
a reason that they didn't stick to their
guns
there was a reason the community
the community said no we're not playing
they don't always listen to the
community that's the problem i'm just
kidding
but would the community the community
these reactions have been different if
they actually did what they said they
were going to
that that's the taliban they didn't do
it correct
i'm going to give you that travis i
would argue that the reason it didn't
work out is because
i think that they looked at the equation
of like well can we fix sunsetting
and then they saw how much content they
would need to create
right after they have to up the amount
of guns
content they're making every season they
were just like dude this isn't feasible
what's the easier i
have consistently proven that they
cannot do it
exactly can i make a counter argument to
that
please since they hired
weapon specific uh team members which
they did i think it was like
two three seasons ago i think it was
like pre-season of the chosen
it's definitely gotten better like we
get a depth
which i was not expecting there to be
new adept weapons this season after last
season i was like halfway convinced that
it was just going to be
you know we're getting pally again and
which is going to be the same thing
but they brought three new weapons
they're adding shrug specific weapons
gambit crucible like they're they're
doing better there's a lot of seasonal
weapons to chase now
especially from the last two seasons if
you take the season of chosen and
splicer loop pool
it's actually pretty big it was like
what is it like 60 70 weapons at this
point
can we be honest about these shadow keep
and dreaming city
weapons can we be honest
the rehash was just
made a thousand perks in each column of
this like
i just i don't again i hate going i'm
i'm team developer i love developers i
don't want to be disrespectful i don't
know how to code
i don't know how to make a game yeah but
to me
when i saw those re-issues of those
weapons i was extremely disappointed
i was just like from a legal standpoint
to be honest with you because they're
still selling forsaken and shadow
keeping shadows
right stuff that was sunsetted gear or
doesn't have a source
of weapons anymore that's really a legal
problem to be honest with you
at the end of the day no because it's
it'll be in their their drm
did the arm yeah it just to me i i still
feel they're behind the ball as far as
whether you know whether it be the
resource thing or whatever it is you
know
um making another game or what have you
would matter or whatever
you know they just haven't proven this
base
we just gobble up this content in such a
fashion
they cannot seem to keep up that's just
always been
destiny's achilles heel and and that
that's my whole thing so to travis's
point
if in theory they would have had those
weapons ready to go
and and those replacements but we went
through almost two seasons
where they took all this stuff away and
we're like well
when beyond like we're like what are we
really chasing right after we got
the the europa stuff it was it was
really a light pull
it took them a while to refill that
that's all i'm trying to say
that was ground zero yeah i mean yeah
when it's zero
yes yeah ground zero is tough because
they're literally starting from a blank
slate but if they had
i mean you know done that on a huge
release like
what we're expecting witch queen to be
where they bring i mean maybe they bring
in
80 weapons is anybody going to care
about some of their old favorites being
sunset no because you have things to
actually go out oh
i know that you guys are you were
mentioning the power creep thing at a
base
level that is what the primary solve of
sun setting does
yeah but more than anything it solves
lewd incentive issues because if i
continue to get primary like
i have heritage i have no reason to ever
go
farm another precision shotgun again
because i have that
and it's insane like i'll never have a
reason to go do that do i ever have a
reason to go farm another 140
that's not the adept fate bringer it has
the two best perks in the game
i have no reason to i have a regular
favorite like that and i'm good
yeah i mean like i'm just
all i'm legendary no but here's the
problem is we're ahead
i was gonna say here's the problem with
exotics
he's mentioned things like anarchy
izzy's
if something like gallohorn was in
destiny 2 from
early on rockets have had their ups and
downs of power and things like that
but it's still just the issue of travis
mentions like the nerfing
going up and down like hey rockets were
trash for
two years or however long they were in
the dumpster and you're like hey
rockets got a 30 percent buff that's
their way of like cycling the meta
as opposed to them saying hey here's
some rocket launchers that have been
good or bad hey we sunset
gallihorn it had its heyday hey now
we're gonna bring out
a new one instead of having to do those
other things it's like
for me the we have so many exotic
weapons now
and they're looking at doing catalysts
to make them stronger
they may as well at that point make a
new exotic
yeah and give you some freshness to go
after as opposed to hey that thing
that's been in your vault for like
i don't know about two years go pull out
a copy
infuse it because that's still a thing
you have to do because it was an 1100
weapon
then go grind out 500 things of this
weapon you haven't used in a while
feels about the same hey you get the
catalyst that feels different
as opposed to what you would like
cognito what if now in the world instead
of going to get us
you know catalyst for sunshot that you
know that one already exists but say
that one unlocks and be like hey it's
got new range and now it explodes four
times as much be like what if
sunshot had been sunset with you know
start of destiny 2 and now there's like
this solar thing that looks absolutely
ridiculous and they gave it a twist of a
new perk
as opposed to having these exotics hang
around but that way you cannot have to
always power creep
up you sunset the exotic you get your 18
months or whatever with it
and then when you do see a new solar
hand cannon you're like hey we haven't
had a solar hand cannon a little while
we have legendaries that fill those
holes and that's the key which you guys
are talking about
sun setting sunset too much they were
worried about recluse they were worried
about mountaintop they're worried about
revoker those three were huge huge
problems in their own rights each
if those would have gone away but they
wouldn't have like taken out
as you said archetypes or i need a void
scout rifle there's like
one even now if you go look for a void
scout rifle there are very few
if they would have left like options in
those arc level legendary archetypes and
then continued to cycle they killed too
much
of the legendary world but then now the
issue with exotics never going away and
never being sunset
is that issue of power creep as he's
saying and we're gonna go through the
nerf thing
at some point anarchy is gonna get shot
in the face and left to bleed out
and we're gonna go have to find
something else which they'll give us
but if anarchy had its time to shine and
then it was
bye-bye then you're like anarchy was
cool got to live another day and then
cool
later on we'll see a different grenade
launcher doing different things that
they can still make powerful
because of that so it's like it's a
combination of literally everything you
guys said
they sunset way too much stuff exotics
having too long of lifespan have the
issue of power creep especially now as
we have the mods making them godly
and then the combination of like with
exotics themselves and legendaries
if they live too long then how do you
continue to like have that lewd
incentive
so it's literally everything you guys
are saying it's just they haven't
unfortunately taking
three steps down the wrong path instead
of what we all would have hoped for like
travis was hoping for
hey if you're gonna drop 50 weapons and
then the next you know a couple weeks
later hey we got these other things
coming in we left you guys a lot of
options but we killed some of them
we're going to get on this cycle there's
enough in here they they bit off a lot
more than they could chew
but unfortunately now that they've
stepped back they've really shot
themselves in the foot in the world of
power creep and making other things
desirable because of what is still
existing
sorry i honestly think it i honestly
think it's just a matter
of they implemented sunsetting before
their team was ready to deliver
exactly i think if they did sam
if they did the sun setting like at
witch queen release
their team would have been ready for it
they would have had the staff in place
they would have had the
you know the their kind of like uh
pattern of releasing new guns in place i
just think
it was too early and they gave up on it
too soon
i agree that's a problem that probably
won't
get addressed like to be honest like i
don't i don't see them re-reverting to
go back to sunsetting
so yeah they're just gonna they're just
gonna nerf it and they're gonna say that
it's not sunsetting they're gonna say
anarchy got a a damage decrease which is
essentially going to be a sunset they
just won't call it that
yeah yeah my my final point is i i would
just say that um
my final point is just this that at the
end of the day i feel
the percentage with exotics in
comparison to the whole entire loop pool
is still not comparable i still think
it's a smaller percentage
in comparison to legendaries the second
thing is
if we introduce the new exotics and we
sunset the old
right inherently there's always going to
be those exotics
that are going to stand head and
shoulder over other exotics
and we're still going to have the same
thing where we're still going to nerf
the new sun shot version 2 or anarchy
version 3 in a different form with a
different skin
so my thing is if you're going to do all
that
right to invalidate the the player
investment
then you better give me something to to
to
to make me feel good about it you don't
say hey what i what i want to feel good
about
is anti-cheat and pvp maps
and you you better do something with
this game on a core
level that you can justify taking away
player investment and i always say new
engine and new things
and then it will ease the blow for me i
was like this is where you and i will
different
co-hosts we're gonna do that from time
to time of course you always say
yeah we do it's fine um you always say
it's like
not respecting player investment oh it's
definitely not no no i'm saying like
i get that but i was like no game
honestly
is like destiny lives as long as it has
right so you're like how like you've nev
like
we did this before and it was always the
idea of like how long is long enough to
respect like you've had that gun for two
years
you're not done with you do and that's
the issue it's not about done it's about
all right
because destiny is unique but we're
going to go on for the attention i
know this is happening but because
destiny is unique
destiny is one of the most
original games in the sense of look just
look at the gala horn for example right
look at
look at how beautifully it is designed
from an artistic standpoint
right and then the way the gun get that
people destiny is unlike any other game
you have a unique emotional connection
to that gun i don't know many games
that they're designed so well right
that you you personalize that even with
legendaries to the extent because
sometimes they think they need to kill
they don't make you ever put that away
and you get that type of attachment to a
gun
if they don't force you to put it away
you're never going to want anything else
that they make
and that's i think the issue is it's the
eternal struggle right
right it doesn't always exist in an mmo
but
i mean but that's on the that see but
that goes back to
it's not sun setting that is the issue
is the core
it's the core design philosophies of the
game that need to reward your time
better
number one so that you don't feel like
you're being cheated and disrespected on
your time investment
and two they need to come out with new
stuff like i would rather them spend
new time like time developing new
powerful guns
that make us want to play the game which
is the most important
part of this whole this whole discussion
that we're talking about is like
what's gonna get me to grind this game
more is it keeping a weapon at the top
of the meta that shouldn't that
should be sunset but we're afraid to do
it because we're afraid of you know
people being offended that their time
investments been uh you know compromised
or absolutely we reward them and bring
them stuff that they
really want to go chase that's continue
to do like that's the struggle
and all i'm telling you guys is like i'm
going to find a duke right right so
shout out to maddie i'm gonna put his
business out
he put out a question on defining duke
recently and was like yo
you know they're asking for someone new
getting into destiny right and he's like
cog
i played in d1 i haven't played d2
tell me what is going on right because
he's like yo
i heard that they are they got rid of
weapons
and the minute i heard that i'm out
that's what casual people say there's an
emotional connection
we can't deny it you know what i'm
saying this is that 80 20
thing again the 20 for the sake of the
game and hardcore
i feel y'all you know what i'm saying
for the power creep for the reefer i
feel ya
but that 80 that played this game and
they're new to the game and you
they got their beloved thing and then
you say your beloved thing you can't
play with you can't touch you look at it
it's useless it don't feel good see
that's the problem
hold on that represents more of the
majority of
gamers than y'all think and that's the
struggle that bungie's gonna have to
deal with
i agree [ __ ] but they need to get you
said that this
you said this listener played d1
right they they sunset every weapon in
the sandbox
every year in d1 right and they left so
he should be at home with that then why
is he saying that he's not created
because he said that why he's not
playing do you want that's what they
that's what he told me
maddie was like i heard that sunset
stuff i'm not playing i'm not doing that
he said you're not going to take stuff
away from me i think you can work
with somebody's investment and their
time
if you let them keep the weapon for a
little bit
and then say hey this is essentially a
new game a new platform like when d1
transitioned to d2
everybody understood why you couldn't
bring your stuff across right because it
was a new weapon
because destiny's changing its model it
kind of needs to think as every major
expansion as its own game
and i think players need to start
thinking of it like that because that's
what it is right like
yeah destiny 2 vanilla is a very
different game from first weekend
you're working logically but it's not
going to fly toward a casual play i'm
just telling you i mean that's
like
are the players are gonna get upset that
they only have 18
months with a gun that's a year and a
half they pro they realistically
probably don't even check in that often
are those really the players you should
be building your game for or is it going
to be healthier
if you cascade it down from a higher
level where there's incentive for
every level of player all the way down
to that then it
more you're gonna bring more people in
the door that way
if you have incentive at every single
level and you have new stuff to chase
that gets people excited
it's just i don't know i i don't destiny
became
just so near-sighted a little bit the
sandbox became a huge problem when they
decided
not to put a three or universe or
anything else and give what cognito
wants
that easy clean slate that's the easiest
way they did it in d1 to d2 they're like
blew up the tower you got nothing we
have to start over
even though you may have a character we
got to get a whole bunch of new stuff
they they paint themselves into a corner
shout out to new red who said that
multiple times
they have painted themselves into a
corner now to where they're worried
about power creep
and they're not willing to sunset and
that is a problem that is going to be an
issue on both sides of that because
if you want to make new stuff you got to
make it you got to have a reason to want
to go get it okay
if you have stuff that's absolutely at
the pinnacle of what you're allowed to
survive anyway
mods are going to make some things a
little less but still anarchy is just
insanely busted
how are you going to make something good
enough that people want to incentivize
it but doesn't involve power creep and
none of it ever goes away
that's the that's this cyclical issue
and whether it's a legendary an exotic
half of the exotic armor may as well be
sunset because you may as well throw in
the garbage anyway
and try again but i was like same thing
with weapons they're the same
way they're gonna try it with a catalyst
like
you have people building weapons now
instead of saying hey
the freaking void pulse rifle that i can
never remember the name of that has
cosmology on it
thank you i don't know why that is on
that one that one kills me but it's like
say graviton lands hey it's got a
catalyst now
that it does something crazy cool it's
like wouldn't i be more incentivized to
be
or more excited to be like hey let me go
pull this thing out of my vault
that i have had for four years a
hardcore
player you guys are the hardcore i get
it it's a
mentality hold on but here's the no but
here's the issue like
what if this person hey my brother
played d1 or d2
year one hasn't played in a while he
jumps back in
like they've made changes in weapons
where there's different stuff to it now
so they've sunset weapons in a different
way from what travis said
they have random rules on them now they
have better perks and things
they're finding different ways to sunset
in quotes
right but so yeah so that's why i was
like the whole idea of deleting
something is like
well how about this like you know i have
the the hand cannon from the leviathan
raiders that's the
dude it's trash there's so much better
stuff now that's all we ever want to say
and that and the idea of sun setting is
basically instead of
nerfing things and going through these
cycles you remove that
like bad feeling from the equation and
say dude there's new guns out there
they're all really cool there's some
cool there's nice exotics
all that stuff you had dude it's just
it's outdated it's been three years how
long do you need
now you're back in like that's not sorry
because we're beating this down
we do need to move forward the final
point i said i think that
above said it best with a kind of a
marketing background
it's just about the way you do things
and to give some
the way you handle it from a marketing
standpoint to a player there's certain
things
that just doesn't feel good and i i
i don't envy them on how they want to
have to deal with that
because at the end of the day yeah that
that's the struggle for them because
the sunset on a base level
to a casual doesn't feel as
it doesn't feel good but it it's
lessened with the
nerf or whatever and i think they're
able to get away with that
with that fluctuating of the are we
buffing this we're not from that we're
buffing this
even though that may annoy the casual to
take it away from him
that is a more extreme thing but travis
i'll let you finish it i'm i'm done yeah
we would go
if i if i'm if i'm a marketing guy at
bungie and i'm trying to sell casuals on
the whole weapons refresh sun setting
thing
the way i'm putting it is i'm putting
myself in the shoes of a casual player
and if i'm a casual player i actually
want sunsetting to happen because
if i'm casual i'm never going to be able
to keep up with the cogs of the world
right of the aboves of the world they're
always going to have weapons that i
don't have access to
they're always going to have that stuff
that i can't get and so
and so a weapons a sunset at the end of
an uh
as a new expansion starts a new year of
destiny is i'm we're cleaning the slate
we're making
all of the uh we're making everybody
equal
and that way it's a casual player if
you're a casual person who's fallen
behind and you don't have any of these
guns
now you're equal now's your chance to
hop back on and
rise and keep up with the game if you
feel like you're fell behind because if
i'm a casual player i'm thinking i'm
behind on destiny all the time
and i can never catch up because now
they're not sunsetting any of this stuff
that i haven't gotten over the years and
so
you can actually you can make sunsetting
using marketing
a good thing that helps casual players i
just think it's the way that they talk
about it
they've let the narrative turn against
them and let the community dominate the
conversation of you aren't respecting us
when that's really not what this is
about at all it's about
making a game that can be fun over
multiple years and you still have stuff
to do in chase
you want to know it's disrespectful and
i'll make it a final point is
getting exotics like tommy's matchbook
that's disrespectful yeah come on dude
there's gotta be better ways
to excite people with loot and uh if it
means we're getting
exotics like tommy's matchbook and
traveler's chokers
i love
oh i mean them take like ruinous effigy
it had it's fun and then it got like hey
it got the nerf that feels like crap so
i was like no
it was immediate that did that was that
one came out of left field it was like
why did what
and nobody was even feeling like hey
this is too broken uh so yeah it's like
we have definitely beaten us to death
it's been a while since we've talked
about it
it's been a while since this came up and
annual discussion yeah
our annual but we had like i'm glad
above and travis were both here
because yeah it's one of those things
that bungie has the impossible task of
trying to
give a lot of people the incentive to
play their game
be it casual be it hardcore and they
have also the difficult task for both of
those to keep it fresh and as you said
rewarding their time
it was people different people are going
to have a different opinion depending on
their experiences and what they go
through
what i feel is an entitlement is where
is cognito saying i'm disrespecting
their time and that is truly a different
perspective
depending on where you're coming from
and that's one of those things they have
the impossible line to walk and i don't
envy them at all
because like it's a hard equation for
them to do we
and again you've seen community feedback
some like sometimes
the community like the loudest spoken
one is not the one that they need to
listen to
and sadly it's like sunsetting sticking
around as travis said
helping you know the new player feel
fresh every year
could have been the thing that helps but
now if witch queen they have to try and
figure out how to manage
two and a half years of weapons going
into witch queen to make things feel
fresh and cool
and balanced yeah that's a nightmare for
the devs too
they have to worry about two years of
legendary and exotic weapons
and make sure that the bosses aren't
just going to fall over like oh for sure
for sure absolutely
yeah that's a whole nother thing it's
like they have they have set the balance
down
yeah and the last thing is is player
population brother remember they're very
analytical driven
they look at what people are doing and
what they're playing what they're not
playing
and a lot of their decision making is
based upon that
so sometimes those loud people do go
away
so it's a tough day it's a tough day
well that was the biggest tangent i
think we've had in a little while but
that's still fun
above sorry we said this might go long
but maybe not we hit the long categories
oh it's been a while it's all good
it's been a while since we've had
answered this mastery apologies man
yeah shout out to those of you who made
it this far if you get this far in the
comments
please reply somewhere or tweet at us
with hashtag
do want to get to it there you go um
grand master and conquer gilding
so back when we introduced grand master
nightfalls and conquered title with
gilding seals still nine months away we
wanted to give players
a hard-to-reach goal that measured both
skill communication build crafting
they want to make grand masters tough
obviously uh
we added better master working material
drops adept weapons and mods and title
grinding
seasonal challenges and plus 10 season
power means it never has been easier to
get the pinnacle and artifact power
needed for the season
i love how they lift these list these
bullet points and i don't know if i
agree with any of them
the addition of a catch-up node which
was currently appears that you can buy
through the season
all of these things don't strike me well
but i'm going to finish this reading and
then we're going to talk about this one
uh thanks to these changing we'll see a
lot more people attempting grand masters
i don't know what those numbers are
later in season 15 so apparently not at
the start
we're planning to make the following
changes to grand master catch-up node
to let players guild their title earlier
in the season
while also addressing our excuse me our
concerns over single strike
being a boon for high tier awards over
the last three weeks of a season
grandmaster catch up node will become
available at the same time the grand
master difficulty is available
so as long as you have the conqueror
title but have not gilded it that season
you can use it each grandmaster
nightfall will be available if the fire
team leader has not completed the
gilding triumph for that strike during
that season
in other words you may play each
featured strike for the season to earn
your gilded tighter
title after that you can't once you've
gilded your title the catch-up node will
no longer be available okay so two
pieces of this first
above as you do guides for these things
much less other stuff
thoughts on where grandmasters where
they're what they've been through
with you know now adding adept weapons
and things like that where do you think
grandmasters stand
at this point and then the other
gentleman just at least from the round
table since you guys are more pvp still
from what you hear
but above where grand masters for you
as an endgame piece
he's gonna preface this hold on he's
gonna preface this one real quick yeah
just because uh
i know travis and cognito are struggling
on the pvp reward side like that that's
like inside of side but careful with the
forgotten yeah i actually feel like
they're pretty
they're in a pretty good spot with gm's
i feel like a lot of people it's become
a popular activity because
it is the aspirational activity they're
rewarding
uh it keeps things fresh you have sit
you you know
one new one a week for six weeks and
it's something to work towards every
season people are like oh it's gm
season's finally back like i'm stoked to
hop back in
they're very rewarding for your time in
terms of exotics ascendant shards like
all that stuff
um where i think they really fi and
especially like
the addition of uh adept weapons even
though we haven't had the best of adept
weapons azumi is gonna be really good
um so definitely farm that one if you
guys weren't planning on doing it as
irene but that's me
yeah um but like for the most part like
the
the adept weapon rewards having in the
ability to guild a title
i think is all great uh the materials
are great i think where they're falling
joy right now is actually the gilding of
the title itself
which it sounds like they're changing
and that's fine
i just wish that it was a permanent
thing i don't understand the whole
mentality of having like uh
the number go away at the end of the
season i find that really bizarre
like what what is the harm in having me
show off that i'm a two or three time
conqueror
in the off season of gm's i like i i
don't get it
you know that there's gonna be a fourth
one to come the following season that
you're going to want to chase
i just find that really bizarre um the
node change i think is good
i think bungie's going to have
nightmares on their hands keeping that
from getting exploited and
somehow people finding a way to farm
lake of shadows at the beginning of the
season
you can literally guarantee that's why i
mean two-person carriers just make the
other person the f
well you have to have the conqueror
title you have the confidence the thing
is like they're they're saying oh well
you know you need to redeem
like you need to guild the title i don't
know i just feel like there's gonna be
something that comes up with that where
people are just gonna be farming lake of
shadows over and over again
well hopefully it pans out but knowing
you know the community and the things
that they find i'm sure there will be
some wait for cheese forever's video
yeah exactly
and then um i really i feel like if they
introduce that
uh that node like so basically the
selectable playlist that happens at the
end of the season
i always look forward to the end of the
season because it allows me to
you know take people to farm different
gm's at the end of the season
or you know just have something to do to
fill the time at the end of the season
which is usually like pretty
slow right so like having the ability to
do that
it's gonna be alone yeah and next
season's gonna be very long
um once you have that gone from the game
you know maybe you don't have you know
people don't need help with lake of
shadows as much right so
i don't know you're not going to have
that farming aspect i it sounds like the
playlist is still going to stay intact
so like each week
you know you have the the dedicated gm
and then
you know you can you can guild your
title early or whatever but
the note is a good change i hope they
bring it back towards the end of the
season too
and that it's not just an early season
thing and it goes away i think
that would literally just bring back the
problems that they solved
with the node um which is well actually
i guess it wouldn't
because you'd be able to you'd have it
available if you haven't done them but i
guess like
the fomo of um you know if you missed
one out but i guess that definitely
solves it so never mind
on that point but i don't know if the
farming aspect at the end was always
kind of fun for me
yeah um but i don't know we'll see i i
think
i think they need to change how the
gilding of the titles works
uh for everything like every single
title i don't i think it's bizarre that
it just goes away
um and i think they could do more than
just a number like add
make the banner underneath your
character like oh
yeah this is stuff we talked about
before like dude yeah you on our same
page
and then at the end of the day like dude
cosmetics cosmetics cosmetics i know
youtube supreme eververse will always
you know probably prevent that from
happening but it gobbles up all those
cosmetics man
you wanna i mean you want to keep
players invested they want to look dope
people want to know where they come from
to do those activities how they look
that way
that's how it was in d1 um i know that
like i know eververse is like a huge
cause for that um
which is understandable businesses need
to make their money but um
the free-to-play pay-to-play mix that
they have going on i feel like there
needs to be
they need to find a better sweet spot
because it's ruining some of the end
game incentive for the really hardcore
players and then it's
all about it i don't know i could go on
for a long time but
i mean the trials wings from d1 are the
primes example of
rewards where you put in the time you
kick ass at a difficult activity
and you get to look like a badass and if
you walked around the tower with a
conqueror like
i don't know have fun with like put a
gold crown on your head that looks
obnoxiously large or something
ridiculous where you're like strut let
me shine
yeah like do something over the top like
you are in concord
you did gm's how do i get like okay
you're like that actually looks cool
nothing in the tower stands out anymore
i agree maybe
it could be as simple as like you
literally the adept weapons that season
yeah there's minimal difference between
an adept ver especially if they're going
to stay to the model that they do with
the adept weapons now
where it's like a very minimal
difference they slot you know the adept
big ones mod which is like the only
thing people really care about for pve
give us a really cool skin for hung jury
or zooming like something
really cool that you grind that conquer
title out and you earn that same
like flawless you go you get the
flawless title
you get some really cool skin for the
igneous hammer that no one else has
like that would that would grind for
that i think a lot of people would and
they're not even selling that in every
verse so reach
it preach it like that wouldn't even be
that much dev
resource obviously i don't know anything
about that but it's like
come on man weapon skins yeah
no you want it you want it just to jump
in real quick um
i i always feel that's what
ornaments should have been doing yeah
like some of these ornaments are
fire for these weapons right yep and
i get it like you said above it's a
business i get it but
why can't we unlock those extravagant
style looking ornaments as rewards for
these end game content
i always have to run over
to test you know say it and see what's
going on
yeah it's like and now it's accessible
in the linux
you can access tests from space
you can't get bounties from space still
but you can get tests yeah you can
differ i'm talking in-game don't make me
pull out my phone
i'm so with you money money money money
money money money money money money
i keep it short i'll let you go yeah i'm
wait 100
above on all those points because at the
end of the day
the end game stuff needs to be
especially this
you're having people going through grand
masters and getting
titles why are we resetting anything why
is there a number such
as anything what is so bad
about this person saying yo he did it
five times
let him rock let him flex he's the man
we can we can all shower him with our
remotes when we see him come through the
tower
title and they can't sunset weapons part
that blows my mind about it too
is like so many of the casual players
will play the launch of a
of a dlc right like a new season splicer
comes out they play two weeks
they grind you know they grind the
seasonal activity whatever
but they that's when those players might
see
that three or four above your head and
be like whoa how did they get that or
like
some really cool skin that you have and
be like wait a minute how did like how
did they get that
you might just pull them in to be a
harder like a more of a hardcore player
to actually go and
you know figure out okay where the hell
did they get that now i'm gonna go
try for my conqueror whereas like now
that's just not a thing because that
title just disappears at the end of the
season no one knows that you've done
that
it's just it's weird it's bizarre i
don't i don't get it you're right you
know he's so sick and tight
yes dude they're doing
they'll sunset everything but not call
it sunset it's a season reset
yeah so i guess because the original
question was like what are your thoughts
on
the state of grand master nightfalls and
like for me
the biggest problem with grand fest
grand master nightfalls has always been
much faster than furious
and furious
grand master nightfalls is that they are
strikes
that's my biggest problem with them
because strikes already exist and they
have a purpose of
providing like this casual story focus
like you know uh pve uh game type
and then grandmaster nightfalls are just
are artificially inflated difficulty
versions of those exact same events and
regardless of how rewarding they end up
making those and i think they're doing a
lot better like i
did a bunch of grand master nightfalls
last season and i was like okay yeah i
can see
the you're i'm definitely getting a lot
more out of it than i i
got out of trials unfortunately uh sad
me
uh but um i you know i saw that part of
it but the problem is there's still
strikes
right and i feel like there there is a
need for some other kind of game mode
like
the last year of d1 where they had that
prison of elders mode
uh where it was like a game it was like
a horde mode
yeah it was like a horde mode where you
went in and you you killed all the
enemies in a room accomplished a little
goal then did a little boss fight
something like that
i just think that there needs to be some
other sort of pve mode so that i don't
feel like
everything in the pve universe is either
i'm doing a strikes
or i'm doing a i'm doing a a raid and i
think dungeons are another good thing if
there were an exclusive kind of short
little mini raid like a dungeon
that was as hard as a grand master
nightfall as long as it's new content
i'll do it and that's that would be
great but this is
again we talk about this every week like
what's destiny's biggest problem we need
more content
way easier said than done right like
obviously but
that's my biggest promise i just i just
still think that they need to not be
strikes because i'm sick of strikes and
by the time i get to doing them in grand
master mode i'm just like this is just
hard just for the sake of being hard i
beat these guys last week and they were
a bunch of wimps now that now they're
sweet now they're now they're just god
tier because you made them god tier i
don't even know if it's genuine
you just decided that they're stronger
than me now i do i do agree with you
on that aspect like in a perfect world
we would get
new activities but i think like um i
remember this quote from datto from a
video like a long time ago he was like
you know destiny had become
so wide instead of being tall and dense
in like what they create i don't think
it's necessarily a bad thing that
um you know there's multiple levels of
difficulty
for these grandmasters and varying
rewards i actually think that's like
healthy
i think for you like you you might not
enjoy those
and they definitely need a refresh of a
new core playlist i complete like i
100 am on board with that i just don't i
don't necessarily think it's a bad thing
for the game like it might not be the
most innovative thing
but at least you're building depth on
like what has made
destiny destiny over the past
six years like strikes are a very
popular game mode and then people want
to like work their way up and
and conquer no pun intended like the
hardest difficulties of those playlists
and get rewarded for it
i think that's cool but yeah like to
your point i'm like i mean i
i want something new too like i want a
better version of like gambit like a new
core playlist that we can find which i
think which queen honestly is that
called gambit like crime
i remember remember there was gear
associated they had they had stat
bonuses
and set bonuses
moving forward that we always wanted
like division and other games and
yeah that yeah or even if they reworked
battlegrounds to be more of like the pbe
end game if they made battlegrounds as
hard as
uh nightfalls and just put you in that
mode that would be cool they could re
reuse that old seasonal activity
there's a lot of potential i just i just
don't think it should it's like
we already retread so much ground in
destiny
do we really need another game mode or
the end game
pinnacle activity that you do once you
get to the top as you do the same
strikes you were doing when you were
20 power you know what i mean can i just
can i ask a question
and this is kind of this goes back no
you made a conversation of revealing uh
dang
we're talking about you know revealing
trials maps how cool is it last season
though when they released
uh what was it called proving grounds as
a gm like on that reset
and people were in there all day like
that was i remember that day it was like
an event
people were trying to figure out like
how the hell do we beat this it did feel
like
new and refreshed i think part of it is
like we've been playing the same strikes
for
four years now you know what i mean
whereas like if they were pumping in new
strikes
i feel like it would keep that fresher
game like yeah
yeah it's like why did they they rip so
many maps out and i know it's like
assets and stuff
i i know i know it's just yeah they've
ripped too much out and now they're
trying to like
claw back to some level of decency
because when you rip
seven strikes out you give us one and
then two d1 strikes which were like
it was cool like the first time but
you're like yeah i've done this for
three years
now let's just tack it on to my fourth
year reviewing devil's lair so
that's where travis is yeah i was like i
mean pvp maps
it's cool because it was brand new like
i actually wanted to go
just like figure out what it was all
about it was really cool
yeah pvp world's like you guys get a
whole strike part of a season
you guys can tell a whole story and
build up to this seasonal thing and you
can't put
one map in there one pvp map like
that's uh when it comes i feel like by
now they might have accident they might
have added another pvp
map by accident after two years like at
this point like
they would have just done it like oh we
did that
didn't mean to happen it just sort of
came out of our yeah
it almost seems like they've
intentionally not released maps is what
i'm telling it's like an accomplishment
at this point
yeah because there's a whole bunch of
maps in d1 that they could easily put
easily
by by the way gambit is like dead in the
desert somewhere because gambit had six
to start with and then they just lost
two of their six and it's like
and you lost most of your modes we kind
of consolidated they just they took
gambit and they're like
that's all that's left yep so i mean and
how gambit is
one of the three pillars when you're
like oh solstice is out what do you got
to do
crucible gambit or strikes how is gambit
even in that list when you don't even
talk about it
imagine being a gambit main in destiny
uh yeah we talked about pvp versus
right are there gambit names is this
one i think benji is one and but
he's like the only one no i'm kidding
but like
imagine a seasonal event that brings a
new map
like as as a as a road seriously such as
no expectation
this is
we get enough participation they bring
out the i mean that's maybe not the best
idea
but you get the point like what if what
if solstice brought a new striker like
whatever that was brought a new pvp map
like dude that would be so
cool in destiny
epilogue opens up the scourge camp as a
pvp
arena close range just that little and
it's like epilogue opens up a pvp map
and everybody loses their mind
and still europa's over there like yep
we're still waiting on my snow level how
you doing
yeah that one blows my mind i still
don't understand and we lose 13 pvp maps
like
that's crazy oh stockholm bro we've been
beaten into submission
man yeah save me [ __ ] shave me
that's where we at now
top of them like how dare you say that
how dare you
you came in yeah yeah yeah you can't
talk about my game like that only i can
talk about my game like that
only i can talk about my baby in this
abusive relationship
oh my god yes this is what the joys of
passion in the stockholm center
make a weird concoction of hoping for
the future
and i feel like that's what we always do
in destiny is the future
what is
yeah so that feels like what we're
always doing in this game is hoping for
the future because we always see
destiny is the game of potential and it
has been the franchise of potential
and we're always like hey what about sun
setting or maybe pvp we always want
something more and then we just yeah and
then somehow we've had these weird steps
recently so
hey as i was gonna ask when you edit
this
when you edit this episode can you put
hope for the future
in the background of you just talking
right now like is it possible to just
get
that song and just kind of like make it
kind of rise
a little bit and then go away
unfortunately in the world of copyright
strikes
not even gonna fathom that one because
that will just
if you hum the tune too much i'm
probably gonna get flagged so
um but before we go i wanted to ask a
quick ask
of each of you guys on here because i've
asked some of these guys but above you
get the main one
if you got two or three that's totally
fine because you're the main one as we
wrap
we've set it on and i keep saying this
and i kind of feel like i'm probably
beating a horse here but
which queen we talk about it we keep
looking out for it and we keep saying
these things and i keep
feeling that there's more and more
weight put on it as things like these
discussions happen you're like
how are grandmaster you know titles
going away or are adept weapons really
worth it all these things we wonder
about and then there's this thing called
witch queen
which has been delayed and we keep
waiting and hoping for you
what does witch queen need to deliver to
kind of be a win not saying things have
been losses lately because the story has
been good and seasons are good but
i know season 15 is gonna still probably
be mostly my tuesday
game for story people and stuff like
that and then you'll have some grinding
and you'll do your gm's but it's like
you're gonna have about a six month
season there's gonna be a point where
what is gonna be what are the things in
which queen that you want to see
of the if i were to watch the trailer on
the 24th
and get hyped three things i would want
to see
would be want like if they if they put
them into separate pillars in that
trailer and i were to say
these three things would make it a win
it'd be
building out their core playlists so
it'll say you know maybe they're like
five new strikes five new people like
brand new pvp maps
trials rejuvenated something like that
they they go and they address their core
modes the second would be
one of our biggest raids ever if they
use that phrasing and i know that that's
probably bigger than the you know the
standard four encounter raids closer to
last wish size
i'd be very excited about that and then
the third would be
if they announced another end game
destination i felt like that was the
best thing they
ever did for an expansion was with
dreaming city
having an aspirational location it kept
it fresh from the day one grind when
you're sitting there
you know your eyes are starting to like
you know do the whole thing where you
can barely see anymore because you've
been on the game for 12 hours you're
grinding through the story
get to that point and then all of a
sudden you're just rejuvenated because
you
reach this brand new area and it's all
brand new whereas like
with beyond light it's like okay i've
been to these areas 15 times now playing
through the story
now i'm going back to the same point uh
you know later on in the end game
it doesn't feel as special so i feel
like if they
broke those out again they said there's
an end game destination big raid and
they're
they're you know building up their core
playlist i'd be really really happy
fire nice travis cogg if you guys got
one kind of this is like your uh witch
queen please if you will
yeah i have one i actually thought about
this this week which is
i would like if i could get one thing
from the witch queen expansion i would
like them to break
the mold that they've been in for the
past like year year and a half
um i think the worst thing about destiny
right now
it's so easy to say that one of the
worst things about destiny right now
is that we always know what's going to
happen every season because they've got
this sort of rhythm
and it it the fact that we know it is
making it more grating to me
the fact that i know that there's going
to be some sort of public event-like
activity every season that i'm going to
have to grind a lot
the fact that there's gonna be that
artifact that i have to grind a lot it's
like before the season i
even comes out i'm already nauseated by
the grind that i know that it's had
because there's
no surprises the formula hasn't been
mixed up at all
and that to me is the biggest threat
looming across which queen is that it
shows up and it's exactly what we think
it's gonna be
and if it's that it's gonna be
disappointing no matter what so i just
want them to try new stuff i want them
to like
i think of like destiny one that final
year after
uh rise of iron where things were just
weird like they did that
thing where they re-released all the
raids and all of them had all these cool
new armor sets you could chase and
they added that horde mode prison of
elders and they just did a whole bunch
of stuff that was just like
weird and new and it made us kind of go
like well now i want to know what's
going to happen next i have no idea like
what does the future of destiny look
like
and i feel one of the biggest problems
right now is that we know exactly what
the next season of destiny is going to
look like
and it's so unexciting that we know what
it's going to look like
like i don't know the details i don't
know what the public event like
activity is going to be i don't know
what the artifact is going to be i don't
know the specifics of the story but
i know 85 before the opening credits
have even rolled and i hate that
yeah a mystery a mystery
and it goes back to the same thing in
the dreaming city all those secret
quests that you found and the ascendant
challenges
and then tell us about any of that stuff
and that's what makes destiny
fun and like you know when you go and do
presents for the first time or you do
you stumble upon the whisper mission
more of that oh yeah of course they
literally
just put secrets in the middle of the
screen for the trailer for five seconds
i'd be stoked like
that's what makes it special it's like
there that
piece is where they're always walking
the marketing line of the calendar for
the seasons especially which is tough
because like
how do i sell a season if i just say
season of
the splicer somebody's like
okay and they want to sell that stuff
before it even launches so people jump
in have the big launch day population
numbers go up all that
fun stuff they're gonna be like hey
here's pressage here's
you know you've got a sponge on there
now we already knew that was gonna
happen i was like all right so that was
a thing
and then we knew what was going on but
then as travis said it's like
as soon as you see that you're like i
called most of the season when we saw
that calendar
i was like we've got the six weeks of
the mission we're gonna go through i
didn't know there was gonna be corrupted
fine we got you know we got the um
as you said kind of the public event
thing we got those pieces
and then somewhere in there we everybody
keeps expecting is there going to be
like an exotic quest not this late in
the season
because if you don't get the exotic now
early in the season so you get time to
experience it
and then farm it for these random rolls
or other things now we're like okay are
we on this cadence of
hey if you don't get the exotic in the
first couple weeks there's probably not
going to be one
it's yeah it's like travis said that's
shaking up the formula would probably be
honestly one of the best things but it's
also one of the hardest things i think
right now because
if they're working on building the two
and a half times big studio they're
trying to expand the iep
they're trying to go with what works but
they're also at a point where they need
to shake it up just as much
that is probably one of the biggest asks
but i also know it's
what would do it the most good i think
if they can deliver and that's the big
thing
that's why i keep saying take all the
damn time you need i got enough [ __ ] to
play
sorry no what'd you bro yeah i mean you
guys
killed it all the points valid um not
much
not too much i can add on the only thing
i would say is that uh i think
for me expansions always represent
fundamental
core game play and mechanic changes
and and idea change structural
structural changes
and i do want to i'm with travis like i
do want to see
different i i do want to see them you
know
change up significantly on things that
have been neglected
for a long time you know for me it's
always gonna be
you know the the pvp stuff it's always
gonna be the exotic armor stuff the
legendary armor stuff the way armor
it just for right now just doesn't have
any significant value or usage and
and it doesn't feel the same especially
now with transmog
especially with traffic because that was
like well i'm just going to keep
this guy roll stat i already got of one
piece of armor
and change it to the look i want and
that's it so you know i
really want those those those core i
think what happens is they dip their toe
and then they never go back like when we
talk about like the the gabriel
prime armor stuff like you know we've
been screaming for years we want those
those set bonuses right to sometimes to
get us
out of the the crux of always having to
wear an exotic right
if you had those meaningful bonuses when
you have
a full set of something right then you
know it makes me now
play differently you know i'm saying
value something differently also
narratively i think they're good you
know but we do need proper payoff
there's
pressure on this savathune payoff it
needs to hit
it i mean this is the taken queen we
and you know above it and play it yet
but taking king is
legend it is iconic it is transformative
it has to reach that level this has to
be one of those moments
where people who were not talking about
destiny go wait a minute
okay i need to see that that thai guy
travis review witness
you know and he's like yo this changed
the game
destiny's in a new place it's
rejuvenated
they've addressed the issues and one
could hopi like you said
with this time that they're taken right
and that all all this extra time that
hopefully
this is the last thing i it does bother
me when they said we're never gonna get
a forsaken level style expansion
that didn't that didn't sit well with me
because i
i felt like that was the one of the
greatest moments in destiny
like like how how above how you champion
it right
everything you said the story the
narrative the unlocking of a secret mode
the transitioning from a raid into the
storyline the curse the dungeon
it was beautifully done and it was this
continual thing
from narrative to gameplay to everything
and
yeah it makes me sad that they say yo
we're not gonna get that and i i hope
the extra time affords some some time
into that because i think destiny's at
its best
when it's that so that's all i got i'm
i'm hoping for don't pull him we
we bitched and we moaned but i'm looking
for them man i'm pulling for them i love
this game i think it's some of the best
mechanics you know ever and we just need
to to just do a little rejuvenation and
hopefully they can pull it off and get
everybody
get east smile again get that content
going again get him his armor y'all
get him his arm yeah i was like i want i
want an armor i i have to have an armor
3.0 i'm going to lose my mind
like seriously to a point like i mean as
you said you got a good
you got a good set of armor right now
cool like why are you half my more than
half my gear
really does not change hardly anything
about the game
especially if you've got a reasonable
set already if you've got an ark solar
and void set especially masterwork you
don't need another piece of armor to
drop period
all you're doing is and then the
infusion and honestly which leads me to
my bigger thing
my one big ask leveling has got to be
addressed
that's my one one is the whole world of
what is leveling in this game the ten
points
i mean don't talk about it in his video
you know he got a good one on it yeah
and it's like he said it too it's like
why am i leveling do you take the level
and grind out of destiny for the seasons
is that going to be weird but then if
you have the big expansion
then what's the point in the tin if you
put contest on everything then does
leveling even matter i don't know how
they figure out leveling but this
current setup it sucks unfortunately
it doesn't feel good and the 50 wasn't
working they went back to the 10 which
they already said wasn't working so it's
weird that they went back at all
so i'm just hoping and no offense if any
of you guys ever watch this we
still like your game believe me my i
still log in stockholm syndrome at all
and play it
but it's this weird thing of like i
would love that to change i would love
armor to mean something
and i would love leveling to be done in
a different way to where it doesn't
feel quite so bad yeah
i think they uh they increase the level
cap every year during a big expansion
and then they leave it for
the entire year that's what they used to
do and i think that model worked because
it meant that you getting to that
pinnacle was respected for another year
rather than being respected for like
a week like you reached the maximum and
then the next week the next season
starts and you're already behind again
and that's just
yeah even it makes the it makes the
grind feel pointless whereas
if you get to the max three months in
and then you know you're good for the
next nine months or
to whenever the next expansion comes out
you're like all right well for nine
months
that paid off like that i feel like
that's the way they need to do it or
something similar
and they need to get rid of artifact
leveling that's just so
good what the hell artifact penalty
for resetting and trying different
builds i mean oh my god
i was like that's another
there's about 50 but go for one yeah i
want
uh i don't know i mean i just i want the
boss
to live up to the expectations like
sabathune's been hyped up for
so long i hope like because every raid
boss we get
if they're either some no-name boss that
like we like
or they're like returned bosses or like
you know i mean look at gardener's
salvation bubbles i'm sorry
yeah facts preaching my mind like come
on who where
i i'm sure deep in the lore somewhere
he's of significance but like in terms
of the main storyline that everyone's
been following since d1
i would love for us to have a story like
a long
fleshed out story where you know there's
this back and forth with sabathune
you know we've been leading up with all
the story if we just go in and in the in
the main story
kill sabathune or like there's no back
and forth in the story of witch queen
and then i i mean i hope it's a struggle
and we get to the raid and the boss is
really really hard and maybe you even
meet her in an early encounter and she
beats your ass
and then you have to go back and and
fight her as the final boss again
you need to play taken king that's the
whole time
addresses everything you think
literally did it the way you just said
and that's why i think has a problem
though which is i would say that you
need to do even one better which is
if sabathune is the main villain of the
witch queen expansion
she needs to be alive the entire year
and then at the end when she's no longer
a problem or if she doesn't even get
killed she just gets
chased off or you know walks away with
her tails between her leg but i think
that
destiny not having long-term characters
and especially long-term villains that
stick around because they get
galled or they get you know just
destroyed like way too early
i mean dude he was the perfect example
yeah great guy lots of potential died
way too early
i just think that they need to keep
their villains around longer and if if
sabathune dies
at any point during the launch window i
think that is
it got to be in the rain if it's going
she's going to die she got it right and
i just want to jump
even if she dies on the raid i think
that's too soon because then what we've
known her we've known her for two weeks
then
versus one you know they built her
picture the person who played the
seasonal ex the expansion
didn't play the seasons too much and be
like hey i'm back for the next expansion
thing seem cool hey savathun's here cool
she's gone like
as he's saying you need her you're
talking about player retention what's
going to retain players
more than an ongoing villain that you
don't beat right away that stays season
to season and
i don't know i
or like the very deep story if you
follow it like yeah savathun's been a
presence but you never
we don't see her you visit if if you saw
sabathune
and you knew what you were dealing with
and like maybe and maybe that happens
next season maybe we see her for the
first time who knows
i have no idea right right i hope they
introduce her
like a season or two before we end up
killing her because
then it adds more weight to when it
actually happens you're actually
building up to this moment instead of
oh we're going and doing these missions
we never see her you know we see nocris
here and there who's like
you know her errand boy or whatever but
like you know we never actually
you don't have that moment of build up
and i i would
love that i said you could find her in
the campaign of the raid you can even
beat her in the campaign of the raid but
don't kill her
make her stick around make her have more
plans down the road and more
confrontations
yeah that's what i was saying kingsville
had the same problem in my opinion
you know it's great but you don't get to
know works for longer than what how how
long was it till the raid came out like
two weeks after the expansion and then
something like that they should have
kept they should have kept orcs around
for longer because he was great
and too short-lived well my only thing
would i would say is just that
final and i'm done um whatever they do
i just want them to to really
pray play on the the deception aspect of
her
in the encounter like i want like you
know multiple versions just being
deceived our senses like something
that plays into her being the witch
queen of deception
and trickery and that to me if they can
somehow play on that i i'll be good with
whatever they want to do extend it
kill her i need that aspect of her
personality to shine
i can feel it now deception's veil some
debuff
i like it i like i love that i like that
day
well on that bombshell we should
probably wrap this thing up and let this
man get to it
we have had a fun set of debates though
it's been good yeah it's been fun
what has been a relatively quiet week we
managed to beat destiny
like you know many many times during
this podcast so
it's always fun but before we go as we
tend to like to do
to give the guests a chance to basically
shout out themselves
this time is yours so tell us
what you like doing where to find you
what you got going on and
basically like what to expect from you
if you got any cool stuff in the future
if you have your next god roll that you
might put on the line in whatever it's
all time is yours the platform is yours
chat um i am above i stream
five days a week at twitch.tv above um i
also do guides on my youtube channel i
focus a lot on
end game content like gm's master vog
that sort of thing
um and this saturday will actually be
doing
uh grand master ghana which is a game
show a host uh
in the gm playlist that makes it even
more brutal than
they are intended to be like this week
we're going to be doing a
uh abilities and no weapons run like so
uh only abilities and supers gm
run so like nuke champions and it's
going to be a lot of fun
um and we'll be joined by sweat and
clyde for that one so that'll be a lot
of
homies a lot of screaming and
shenanigans inbound um so if you want to
check that out that'll be live on
saturday
and then uh yeah that that that's pretty
much it
i um love destiny and i'm excited for
excited for witch queen the legend man
salute brother you killing it you kill
it man i love what you're doing that
y'all got to watch that that that he be
doing and then if they don't if they
fail it
they deleting they god rolls and all
that bro they got the stakes like wheel
of fortune
and with you with your loot on the line
that's just terrifying
yeah yeah it's crazy yeah see they're
willing to delete their god rules and
people are worried about respecting
their time oh my god i want to keep it
and they're over here
saying they're going to delete it so
we got 60 days to the new season we're
wait we got time
yeah they're good travis what you got
cooking
that you can talk about just the hard
part
uh yeah i do have an idea for um
for sabbath and uh debuff uh enable
friendly fire
that's that would be a great one there
you go
just nukes your whole team turns yeah
yeah enable friendly fire as one of her
uh that would be beautiful
anyway um so yeah uh uh this week i did
a bunch of stuff for uh ign
uh my review of zelda or sorry not
breath of the wild
zelda legend of zelda um skyward sword
hd went live today
uh which you can check that out on
ign.com i've also been doing a bunch of
uh
uh previews uh from caffrey's team and
you can read about the steam deck on our
site
uh which we have coverage for all month
long as part of ign first
uh and uh yeah i'm also here uh and i'm
working on
uh an upcoming review i think i can talk
about it chris tails
if you guys are familiar with the
background i'll be reviewing that
i just got a code for that today so i'll
be working on that over the weekend
nice nice looking at that that skyward
saw right now
yeah oh please do give it give it
me give it the outro i'm looking yeah oh
i'm looking
he was on espn the ocho for that one so
that's right yeah
absolutely what about i didn't give it a
10 out of 10 like our reviewer in 2011
but
sir cog where is uh mr hoity-toity going
to be hanging out this week oh
brother i'm not gonna do anything
but uh doing the last word with my mates
brown on his head with my my royal
goblin
and he has been he has somebody waving
the big banana leaf and feeding him
drinks
oh why not first though salute above man
definitely
glad to have you in the gap for all evil
put me on to your content
love your analytical approach even when
you disagree i disagree i like his voice
he makes a
passionate play i like it you know what
i said i have a good good conversation
love it it was great to have you always
welcome you back especially if they do
sunset because then you can do your
victory lap
there you go yeah you ain't
just being sitting in the corner with
the frown face and you're even like yeah
no but it's all good but um yeah man
like i said for me
you know what podcast this sunday no
guess we're just keeping it with
the lords so we'll be talking about all
the latest hottest
discussions obviously that steam deck is
going to be brought up we're going to
talk about
reviewing easy games that will be
another topic
and uh travis will we have to talk
offline about that one
um but yeah check us out man sunday 1
p.m iron laws podcast
check us out there and then obviously
you know defining duke
again salute everybody thank you for all
the love truly overwhelming it's just
been really
really cool to see everybody kind of
support me and get behind that and again
shout out to maddie for for making a
decision
and we've been rocking so yeah check
that out defining duke the
free version will be released also on
sunday so
right before i lose podcast you guys can
get the episode if you're a part of the
patreon
you can get that earlier it's already
out now the latest episode
so yeah check that out and of course you
know i'm saying lords of gamer.net
support the home team they doing their
thing
we're not as extensive as travis but you
know we try
what we got that um yeah man yeah i read
your articles just saying no
i appreciate that thank you i appreciate
that and of course
the last word back home at the campfire
i knew i was going to get slandered for
being hollywood for missing one week
but i'm back this is where i like to be
talking that destiny talk is very cool
and e i gave you a nice plug on defining
duke when you uh listen to it you'll
like it
it's uh when you talk actually one of
the writers asked about you know what
they should do for destiny and stuff
like that so
i was like you gotta listen to the last
word i can't give you no bump
there's a joke in there somewhere i'm
just gonna blow right past it
anyway that's a little slew man good to
go have travis
in the round talking at that destiny
talk what's up e what about you man
uh for me yeah so i got a cup about two
and a half weeks basically before i go
on vacation so i'll be gone
early august like 6th and 13th i'm going
to miss both of those fridays so i will
miss epilogue
but i'd rather miss that than the start
of a whole new season so i'm off the
24th you guys will see me live there
um i am going to be trying to put yeah
we'll see if we might do a couple shows
without me hosting it might look
different
but we might have a couple of these two
gentlemen for that because i'm not good
at to it
i'm expert at taking over for other
hosts
i guess it's my thing now it's my kink i
guess i'm just gonna get kicked out and
it's gonna turn the iron lords
or iron lord's last word and all of a
sudden i'm out of here i'm like where'd
i where'd he go
uh but no i honestly wanted to thank
above appreciate your time
i know we kept you long um thank your
stream for the delay we appreciate that
if they want to catch this if they want
to catch this it'll be on my youtube
channel
iron lords podcast youtube channel and
then just like rss feeds basically
everywhere so if you want to tell them
where you've been but honestly
appreciate you coming on taking the time
and also
it's been an awesome conversation
because when we get into tangents like
we do
you definitely you held your own and you
had opinions and it was a perfect time
to have a gm guy on
to give your opinions about all this
stuff so it was a great great time to
have you here and honestly sometimes
just timing works out so
thank you for your time huge respect for
everything that you do and shout out to
your community
who's been blowing it up in here today
so thank you guys who are also in chat
uh but as we were so so much i just want
to say one more time
even though we went long it was an
absolute blast of a discussion
and uh it was a pleasure to meet all you
guys so thank you brother
love that technical destiny talk you you
killed it brother
well we are going to be going to go raid
evan f
1997. evan
uh had him on a little while back if you
guys caught him but this man is king
retrospective we talked to him before he
is argument
so we're gonna go rate him send the love
over to his channel if you guys find
this on
other places check him out as well as
above literally everywhere above tp on
twitter
above on twitch good times there so
thank you all
very much let's wrap this thing up
episode number 158 july 16th it was a
long one but it was an excellent and for
this episode it has been
the last word